Hello everybody!
Oh wait, I do have Discord earlier.
Hey, hello everyone!
Oh my god, my voice died right there.
Oh my god, sorry.
Sorry, Matara's affected me with the hags.
Don't keep her in here.
Hello everybody.
No, I aged like 80 years.
Now I'm just the same age as Matara.
Oh,
she touched me.
The hag virus.
No!
has infected you ah get away you're getting it's contagious
get away jackals oh my god you're still on my what what are
you on your top what what are you oh my god it's my alert
gonna get shorter it's my alert okay i got you're gonna
start no will you stop moving why did you stop oh wait
you're having this problem you're you're back you're back
okay i'm back you're back oh whoa whoa you're whoa remember
we had this problem last time okay yeah but then you we
found out you had internet issues did you not yeah but at
this point like it can't be always my internet issues it can
always be your internet issue let me let me poke iron
verdicts about it but for now you all but it can yeah
because like when men and i when we're in a collab room we
were okay like she wasn't lagging at all it's you it can't
be me it can't be me i'm a tomato right now hello hello
governor as you see i'm supporting my fellow commonwealth
i'm supporting my colonizer but tar here she's harlot
betrayer i oh you know what england has done for us they
gave us a monarchy true true how could you do this woman
born in the soviet union like i've already oh gosh she
pulled she pulled the soviet union card my people are still
you know in serfdom i'm just here to root for the little guy
i know messy not personally i just know of him um so they're
saying i'm kind of low oh they're saying oh i forgot i
forgot to be i sorry guys i also was on a recording setting
as well so so now i'm okay i'm a bit louder now oh matara's
low all right let me up a bit more we're sound guy we're
sound guy oh yeah we're we're missing the english national
anthem i can't believe it all right give me a sec let me do
a british word what what is it it's bell end bell end the
end of a bell the end of the bell yeah you call people bell
ends when they're being idiots oh you call the bell end oh
you call the bell end yeah all right let me up you a bit
more i don't know why you're so quiet i have the same
settings all right i think it's my voice i think it's
because my voice has been kind of hoarse oh all right let's
see also i just woke up yeah me too me too i literally just
posted my schedule today after to colonize by the british i
love it she was i can't believe yeah but like but like oh
hey they're seeing is the argentina nationality no but but
but you moved you moved back to canada so technically like
england's your adopted dad yeah and you still betrayed us i
have to be a little bit contrarian it's part of It's part of
who I am.
I have to play devil's advocate.
You're not.
Whatever the hell.
We're not inviting you to Cho GM, the Commonwealth Heads of
Government Mianic, meaning you're not invited in the Tire.
It's honestly good.
I want to, I don't want to think.
It seems like so much responsibility.
What do you mean?
That's why we have the king.
That's why you have him.
He's thinking for me.
Let me grab my coffee.
That's why we kept the monarchy.
Yeah.
You're not invited to a Poutine Festival.
Exactly.
Even though it was the French that gave us Poutine.
Was it the French that gave?
I don't even know.
Did the French give Canada Poutine?
Who gave Canada Poutine?
Putin gave Canada Poutine.
Oh, no, the country Poutine is.
Yeah, it's a Québécois invention.
Yeah.
Along with...
You're not invited to the Poutine Festival.
Listen, listen.
I am always invited for La Poutine.
the what are these like i'm just doing i'm just doing the
squares that french canadian squares yeah just like is this
is this like a quebecua thing that's the funniest thing to
do is to say them with a really french canadian i see it i'm
not just being like well example like uh sacrament or like
uh calis right but it's like yeah like roll my r's a little
bit like the old people do oh what does all that mean also i
up i up the tar a little bit sound guy is it better i'm just
swearing i'm just swearing yeah but what does it mean um
sacrament is the uh i don't know i i don't sorry i'm like
i'm not a churchgoer and before that i was orthodox so
that's a something in the church chalice is something in the
church it's the little cup that jesus drink jesus blood in
um tabarnak is the tabernacle which i think is a chest in
the church i'm so sorry guys i am not you're not good i am
not catholicism and we have different words in in um in
orthodoxy and i'm not even orthodoxy so why do they need me
higher i'm not i think your mike's i think your mic said
there's a mic yeah let me take off my limiter you know what
i'm never used to people being like you're kind of quiet
that's never happened to me i think your mic settings got
adjusted or something you are quieter than usual you know
what something my computer did have a big crash the other
day because i i lost the electricity and i updated stuff so
maybe did i ashwa my microphone volume hold on that is weird
it's definitely loud because you are quieter compared to the
last I was in call because I had you set up to myself.
You know, maybe it's just because you talk loud.
No, no, no.
Because I had you okay, there's, I mean, both can be true,
but also but also like I had I always see the settings of
every like, you know, settings are safe for everybody.
So like, so you are quieter just because like now, like, you
know, it's not the right.
I turned my gain up.
It's going to make me louder right?
Yeah, am I louder?
No, Stevie?
That's what that's what gain is for, baby.
Oh, my God, you are peaking on your own mic, not me, not me,
but like the mic is thinking you're peaking to the point
that it's staticking you, but like you're not louder.
You're not like loud.
It's just the microphone is trying to stop you.
All right, guys, is it better?
Or does she need to be louder?
guilty what should be my password for my crave account your
crave account i'm just gonna did you did you subscribe
already i'm yeah oh you already paid you're not yet i'm okay
i'm just gonna screen share wait i oh my god i'm going crazy
on the avatar we're doing a watch party i hear you
wow turn up post game matara not pre-gain okay i'll turn her
i'm she's gonna be at she's like at it now guys i don't look
donkey i swear to god i've been a creator before i know it
doesn't look like it but i i just don't understand what's
going on but how did you get that's helon's friend that's
helon's friend yeah that's his boyfriend that's his work
boyfriend it's jude oh they're doing counts they're doing
countdown eight seven six five four three two Two, one,
pull, kick off.
I do.
I got it.
There we go.
We're kicking off.
I have a serious question.
For those of you, you don't have to be aligned at the cult
of Dokey Bird.
But who here is cheering for Argentina?
I just want to know, give me a little Argentinian flag.
In response, nothing.
You're going to have a war in my chat from the English
versus Argentinians right now.
okay real europeans know real europeans know you never cheer
for england in eurovision they always lose they don't even
get oh matara doesn't know the football lord matara doesn't
know the football you know the last time i watched football
genuinely genuinely the last time yeah it was the last time
you watch hold on i think you just screened you were like
did the wrong screen i'm like in Wait, no, I can't see
anything.
Yeah, there you go.
Sorry, I had another time.
I was trying to...
I will call you out.
She had like 40 Twitter.
Yeah, they know.
They know.
They saw me Googling Poutine.
If it was...
You could have been like, what is a bell end?
I was just like, well, I was Googling Poutine because I was
trying to figure out where Poutine was invented.
Because I was like, I know it was like partially French
because I was like, I think it was from Cabequas.
So I had to make sure.
Hold on.
My friend just got pushed.
My friend!
I was going to fly over.
I was going to fly back and be like, how dare you?
It would have been so funny if you just ran on the field.
He's just like, wait a minute.
I thought he was back in Norway.
I did want to say, so real, not to raise my European card.
Real Europeans never cheer for England.
Number one.
Number two.
The last time I watched a World Cup must have been like 2006
or 2004 i'm not yet wait that's that's even that's pre-self
wait you were oh but you're you're you're much older than me
so you're like yeah i was gonna say that better than you but
it was also when like zindin zidon was still playing so like
i know the freaking what's his name um beckham was still
playing it was it was oh my god that's how long ago yeah
beckham was still on the field i used to live in montreal
which had a huge Italian still has and French population so
France versus Italy oh my god oh my god everything was just
going crazy well have you watched any of the matches for
this World Cup only if I'm at a restaurant and they're
playing oh yeah because everybody's just oh my god wait what
happened what happened already it's two minutes it's been
two wait we gotta go to the hockey it's no no these the
crazy thing is like uh both of these teams are very known to
get fouls so it's like who's gonna get the most fouls but
like trying like getting the other team to foul them yeah
yeah yeah what is ronaldino still playing not ronaldino but
ronaldino he was um what happened oh shit bro like why is he
wait why did he cover his head these guys when they fall and
and stop yeah it's their both they have both teams have
really good actors okay he oh messy look at him that's my
little guy again be honest with me all i i forgot to look at
chat once if you're cheering for england who if you're
cheering for ronaldo guys not ronaldo they said matara they
said he's retired for like 15 years now isn't he like am i
yeah i was gonna say is he not like 50 or 60 years old now
he's 46 march 21st okay i was 50 yeah because that's yeah 46
46 yeah because it's like ronaldo's like 40 all 40 plus
that's why he's retiring this was a different guy yeah yeah
no i mean yeah i know but i was saying like similar age so
it's like they usually they retire around 40-ish not a few
twos let's go don't let doki keep you down it's coming home
I mean they already got fouled within the within like the
first two minutes that's crazy that's like a they're like
speed running like so you know whenever they tried not to be
like I didn't foul they raised both their hands up I like
how they're already preemptively raising their arms up
they're like no foul no foul
yeah it's been a really long time since i watched i think
when i watched the cup believe it or not i think it kiev
still had ukraine had a team in the in the world cup but it
like it got eliminated so quick technically every country
has a team for it it's like qualifying rounds so yeah
technically when ukraine had like qualified yeah yeah 2006
people world cup it was all right can have you ever seen
history of canada's world cup participation no we the only
reason why we even qualify is because we're hosting so we
have like a like an automatic buy into the tournament so we
don't have to do the qualify rounds because it's like yeah
we made it just because we're hosting but but we got the top
16 we got the top what are all these what the fuck what are
we are we playing fucking wrestling what is going on i
literally see everybody like like sliding and tackling each
other non-stop you know i wish their shorts were shorter i
can watch this more we're like zooming in all their leg
muscles i wish they played in it's just like like like
you're playing volleyball i think i think watarra is
watching a different sport guys i wish they played in like
two tops like you know like like the bandage two tops yeah
but then there's grass burns that's they're very handsy
today they are like it's only been six minutes and i feel
like there should have been like 20 fouls it's definitely a
contact sport it is it is today it is today for them yeah
this is actually the most handsy they've ever been whoever
wins this goes to the finals on yeah right they face spain
yeah i got my i got paella yesterday yeah i got yes to
celebrate my fellow spaniards we're gonna cheer for spain
versus well it depends okay i would cheer for england if
england makes it through as a what if our fellow common well
if england doesn't make is through i'll cheer it's i'll be
like i don't know honestly is that like the spanish
inquisition or messy you know like it's oh technically it'll
be if it's spain versus argentina it'll be the colonizer
versus the colonized oh my god wait that guy just fell by
him oh my god no he grabbed him ref he grabbed him literally
fell by himself like it's so funny that's what i'm saying
like the the matchup for these two teams is is super
interesting because both teams are either super handsy or
they love to they're really good at acting they love to stay
on the ground ah oh it hurts yeah they're like oh that's why
they have the baptist oh Shit!
Stay on the ground!
Stay on the ground longer so you get the call.
What even...
They're on a date.
No, they're on a date, Matara.
They're hooking hands up.
You see that?
They hooked their arms up.
They were on a date.
Would you have for breakfast?
I have nothing yet.
I should...
Oh yeah, during halftime, I need to walk my dog, so you're
going to have to entertain my chat during half time also i
think there i think there's a limiter on your discord
because i can hear you cut in and out by and i think it's a
discord thing yeah yeah yeah yeah input profile hold on
noise suppression crisp oh i'll do none oh i usually have it
as none just in case oh you are cutting in and out there is
a limiter in place by the way who's limiting me all right i
need to raise raise you up on my disc great all right sound
guy take note of this i know he said nice sound guys like i
should take note of it but sound guy you take note of it
it's like nine point minus 9.8 db minus 9.8 all right now
i'm up there i'm up there right now 25 we are seeing real
murder ball we are thank god that's real football no You
know Murder Ball and Haram Ball?
You know what they are?
No, tell me.
So luckily, you don't have to ever watch Haram Ball.
I, unfortunately, had to watch a lot of Haram Ball.
So Haram Ball is like the meta in Haram Ball.
It's basically, it's like the meta for football right now.
Where they have to delay and stall as much as they can.
So you will see them passing to each other.
Stop every and it would be like 70% of the game.
So like you see what they're doing.
They're passing the goalie and then the goalie passes to
someone else.
They would do that.
They have to run the clock.
So they would do until they get the perfect.
Oh, see, they're doing a little bit of it.
But this is not really.
But imagine that before like.
Did you get a bit tired?
No, it's just they're stalling the clock until they have the
perfect opportunity.
Tight deal.
So it's a one direction.
wait is that hairy stylus how do you that is not hair that i
was like i was like oh how did you instantly wreck he had
sunglasses on listen how did you oh shit you were everywhere
breath oh my god he's grabbing on his leg
and then there's a second guy on the ground like they're
actually wrestling right now oh my god this is the most
contact i've ever seen i love the tension the tension is
palpable it's clean and rivalry oh my god i love oh my god
his knee is so wet and he's like guys but tyler's watching
something different right now
ball is this pleaded rivalry this is cleated rivalry hey
can't get involved harry let's go harry showed him how how
you can how to grab oh they need to show victoria victoria
beckham looking completely yeah yeah i do talk to my chat
about it i thought get you get a wife that just didn't does
not give a about your hobbies he doesn't give a about
football i do want to if now i think she's playing it up on
purpose for the paparazzi shot to the h i don't know but no
way that you're not like even a little bit excited like you
know i think she just literally just doesn't care i i legit
think she just actually does not care because like she can't
do it for the entire match you know like you don't know when
you're gonna get photos i think she can i don't know she's
posh spice though she's literally yeah she's living up to it
she there's a reason why she's posh spice yeah maybe there's
a re i always think about it i'm like maybe there's a reason
we get typecast you know darn it darn it just there for the
vibes he's like all right oh shit oh they oh offside yeah
that's what i'm talking about
the ball i can tell he's like the ball the boy what what
just at the ball and the ball that's so funny why are they
so dramatic what are they going on that's why they have the
bath does you like this game is wild this is a wild fucking
game the fact that this your first world like this is your
first official world cup game is crazy like i've seen a few
of them in bars but i'm not really paying attention this
year this is my first game and i'm sat i'm paying attention
i have wine in the fridge and they're like he literally just
pushed him for no reason yeah no this does happen but this
shouldn't happen within 14 minutes of the game like it
shouldn't happen like from the beginning yeah no the fact
that like no one has a yellow card is a surprise is
surprising well maybe not oh shit oh that that's a shitty
pass if he was just he passed it a little too far a little
too early
i can't wait for my friends uh enemies to lovers arc soon
i i i wonder if they'll have a red card because like this
there's that's i think there's been like 10 fouls already.
That's pretty shit.
Yeah, the fact that there's no cards for everything we're
seeing right now.
Oh, good head.
Good head.
I really love Oh, gosh.
Card crash.
He just tried to hit him.
Brother.
I'm sorry, but the guys on the floor touching their knees.
Wow.
Oh my god.
It's time.
That was exciting.
Oh, good pass.
Oh, the between the legs pass.
All right, anyway, this is murder ball.
Oh, no foul.
That's great.
I need a close-up of that.
That guy literally tripped over him.
What?
Oh, still no foul.
This is crazy.
Oh, no.
now we call the foul i just saw like four car crashes and
they're like maybe that was amazing maybe four was a little
too much maybe maybe just maybe oh my god oh my god oh my
god we're like oh no he's like yeah oh my god look hawk is
so happy this is actually hockey right now happy this is
worse than this is like i would this is supposed to be
murder ball but i don't i think this is like worse than
murder what is worse than what is worse than murder torture
probably a torture ball yeah because murder you're dead but
torture oh at this point we need a new card color for what
i'm seeing right now no blood no foul purple real finally
the football we've all
Warball.
This is warball right now.
Dun,
dun, dun, dun, dun.
Oh, shit, the pass.
Oh, quick.
Push him.
No foul.
There's no foul.
I'm sorry.
He just...
This guy keeps getting pushed.
Oh, hey.
Oh, my God.
It's him.
Is that a beetle?
No, it's Nick Jagger.
Did you say Nick?
Yeah.
Nick Jagger.
Jagger.
Let's go.
Wait, where's Beckham?
I'm here for Beckham.
I know.
I'm looking for Beckham.
Where is he?
There's no way he's not here.
It's a Jagger, man.
The fact that no foul was called for the last.
I don't know foul.
No foul.
They literally keep like, look at Beckham.
They literally just keep tackling each other, grabbing each
other, pushing each other.
acknowledge it like oh my god no foul we're never getting a
we're technically not a foul guys technically not a foul
that is crazy i think they realized there's so many fouls
that they just like the ref is like i don't want to be here
for like five hours guys yeah right because for every foul
they call and for every like time out they have they have to
add the clock since the clock and they're like sorry guys
matara has to be doing stuff later and so does the rep was
like yeah i gotta have i have dinner with family later guys
so like i can't i think they just knew that they were gonna
keep pushing each other yeah they're just like i'm just
gonna call like 20 max and then free for all you could do us
you could just do whatever you want guys i'm not adding more
to the clock they're just like guys guys we all have things
to do later.
Yeah.
Oh, ja.
Good pass.
Good past to the goalie.
Good pass to the goalie.
Yeah.
It wasn't like a tricky shot.
But hey, you never know.
Yeah, you know, no, that's what he wanted to pass to the
goalie.
Did he did?
Yeah.
Look how happy she is.
Is she a famous lady, y'all?
I think I think she's in the stands.
I think it was just some random people are kept in a box no
it's because it has air conditioning there yeah you can see
because all the famous people they're wearing fucking suits
and everything i was like bro that there's no it's and it's
like like what like 30 to 40 degrees too so it's like
probably where um i don't know it's somewhere in america
because they rotate the stadiums a lot so oh wait oh i don't
Where's Messi?
Messi's right now.
Where is Messi?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, what was that?
Where are we going?
We're going.
Nice head.
Oh, good head.
Keep him in a box.
It's just like the floor is lava.
They kept it in the air for so long.
Oh, it's in Atlanta.
It's in Atlanta right now.
So it has to be hot.
Yeah, it has to be hot.
Atlanta.
Atlanta, are you ready for a riot?
Doesn't matter which team.
You say this, but no, I doubt it.
Are you guys ready to riot in Atlanta?
Oh, yeah, it's humid and hot.
That's the worst part, too.
My favorite.
Yeah, because, like, English fans and Argentina fans.
Doesn't matter.
We're having a riot today.
Wait, apparently fans...
are ready wait are fans already like getting the fights at
the stadium that's crazy oh she got blood on his oh it is am
i crazy did i see blood on his elbow it's okay it's just a
flesh wound was that not a foul was that also not did they
not call a foul there too nothing they really want to go
home yeah and the rep they're like unless somebody dies you
are not calling foul they were fighting yesterday.
I remember there was a I saw like because football is like a
very, very serious sport.
And I remember I saw a video of like there was like two
videos, one from the UK and one from Argentina.
But then the one from Argentina they were burning a United
Kingdom flag thinking it was an England flag from a I was
just like they're like they burned the wrong flag and then
from and everyone from uh from uk it was just they get very
very very aggressive in the pub because you're very drunk
you know like the bridge they are the english i just fell
down by himself stay on the floor stay on the floor we need
like one of the english player to also fall on the floor and
just stay on the floor with him Okay, look at my foot.
My pinky.
He literally fell down by himself.
My pinky toe.
Oh, yeah, point.
Sorry, guys.
I think the ball is crooked.
Just letting you know.
Handball.
Yellow card.
I will say I have watched football the last time when I was
you know years ago 20 years ago and and it was not they were
not pushing each other like this no it's just it's literally
just this game it's it's it's literally just this game i
watched a lot this is the most aggressive mr el aguero i
have no idea i don't you guys know you should have a
subtitle after also oh yeah no the last time i saw people
being this aggressive in football is whenever canada plays
kata treats it like oh my god now oh my god goalkeeper
versus versus player oh boy oh oh fight fight i need to see
fight punch the ref kun okay i know about them because of
tower of god tower of god yeah the author named one of the
characters kun after a argentinian player i guess right or i
don't know that makes sense this is yeah this is that's been
the most aggressive of game so far oh good head oh off sides
great head finally a foul he's named after that okay see i
know my lore not to be a weeb i know my lore oh my god he
just oh that was so close what's going on well the thing
about it there's a rule where if a goalkeeper takes out
their own teammate during a play um they they have to it's
called they have to have a timeout slash foul and it goes to
the goalkeeper so like it's a strategic decision to take out
one of your own as a goalkeeper that's crazy so you could
stop he just knocks him in the face yeah yeah yeah and then
like they just need to like stay on the floor because like
uh the enemy team cannot shoot a goal if technically the
goalkeeper is out of commission okay i love that you said
the enemy team
Demonizer as decreed by my king for king and country I
forgot what I was talking about, but it was like It was like
the next stage and I called it an evolution and I'm like no,
this is video game terms Like I can't be using the word
evolution like the enemy team is so funny Yeah, I call every
time I would be like there's new patch notes guys There's no
I was like when they're about to shoot the goal I'll be like
they're all thing they're all thing When they have to pause
the game it's like oh sorry they have to like you know in
league when like oh they have to change the hardware hard
time out there's a word for it i forget darn it hard time
out for what like um half time you know whenever they're
playing they're playing in like video games and then they're
like oh pause and then all the all the players have to take
their hands off the keyboard time out i'm not awake i want
to wake I'm just like Tactical pause tactical pause tactical
pause also it's somebody's birthday my chat Fear they give a
super chat.
Thank you.
It's just high Since it's my birthday.
It's only right that I share my birthday funds with you as
we hate watch both teams Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm a time Are you guys seeing a birthday?
Yeah, do I have to do the Marilyn Monroe chair?
be by Mr. President.
Whoa!
Happy birthday, Mr. President.
Yahoo!
I love that.
Whenever somebody asks me to sing happy birthday, I just,
you know, quote Marilyn Monroe.
Marilyn Monroe.
Happy birthday, dear fear.
Happy birthday to you.
You get a hydration break.
You got a call.
I see you have a little milk.
What is it?
It's tea.
It's their tea and crumpets.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, you're denied from the Canadian border.
You've turned.
You've Americanized too much.
No, the British man's playing it is cuppa.
I see you, PPA.
You got a cuppa.
You want a cuppa?
I got a cuppa.
I got cuppa tea and crumpets.
You got a cup of bellins in your chat.
That's what you got.
What?
can i can i tell you a bell end is also holy that guy ran
straight whoa wait good stats in the same skill he gave me
the boss oh shit he's right oh yeah i was gonna say kick him
in the boss who cares nobody's calling it anyway a proper
cup of tea oi bruv do you reckon england is going to
a riot we're gonna riot in london there's gonna be a lot of
stabbings in london after this oh shit keep going keep going
it's not even a foul the crazy part is that none of that was
a foul i even he's like what's the point what's the point i
don't understand how they're like crashing into each other
oh my god the coach was so bad like how is that not a foul
classes this is so funny the thing i think the thing is both
teams aren't getting called for fouls right now welcome to
meredith welcome to ward ball we're inventing a new new term
i really think they're like hey guys we gotta be done by 6 p
.m so y'all can go to dinner yeah he's like um i had a uh
the the maximum quota of fouls i could call was like And you
guys already maxed that out like 20 minutes ago.
The thing is, guys, like even Argentina is not getting, like
both Argentina and England are both not getting called for
files right now.
He told me that we were watching wrestling.
I would have believed you.
No, this feels like hockey on the grass.
They're like, they're bumping into each other.
It's crazy.
Both teams paid off the rep.
So now he's neutral.
Like, I can...
They're just like...
Oh, yeah, he didn't touch it.
He didn't touch it, though.
He kind of hugged him.
He like...
Maybe they just...
Let me both of them just want to...
They just miss each other, you know?
It's been so long.
Yeah.
I wish it was a stat...
I need to know the stats right now for how many fouls.
It's only been 30 minutes, too.
Oh, my God.
I'd love to see those.
There's like...
They usually show stats for some stuff, but like...
They haven't showed any stats yet right now.
But it really is...
Oh, no, no foul!
what oh now it's a foul is this the first foul we've gotten
no no no we had fouls in the first eight minutes pvp enabled
pvp enabled is it crazy we're in bed wars right now
oh that was a good steal that was a oh shit they're playing
around with that guy
we had 12 through how we had oh we have 12 that were called
i was gonna say we definitely saw more than that but then
forgot like half of those were not called i didn't have nine
percent of them were not called oh my god this this is still
insanity like oh i can't believe this is crazy there is a no
which coach oh he's just like he's just like whatever
how much it's cost to have your ads play in the background
of a world cup too much you can have i would what if imagine
a dokey bird ad that would be yeah i was gonna say i was
like what if i put a dokey bird like everything i've ever
earned and i put it in oh oh my god okay yeah no that had to
be a foul yeah you can't hurt jude nope nope you can't hurt
halal yeah yeah jude is like the line they also won't let
you advertise unless you're like sort of a like you have to
be like a car or something you know maybe they have a rule
that you have to like have these players in the yard they
might there's no no no because there's like there's like you
know katar airways there's no way that like joki i don't
know how to say this y'all have to buy the dog the dog
outfit oh the store is currently store is currently closed
right now it'll be open in saturday though it'll be open up
just in time for my outfit reveal no that's Sunday I still
by the way don't know the thing that you talked about on the
pod oh you'll find out on Sunday you're gonna find out it
was supposed to be on Saturday but we had to like oh there
he is oh it gives me two seconds of Beckham that that's all
I need though that's all honestly I was more excited about
the other guy's knees it was supposed to be on Saturday but
like that's what my schedule is out I like how you raised
his pants there he's like yeah you guys see unlucky no head
for him no head okay you can't just say no head for him no
head for his relationship with his with the ball what are
you talking about that's what they call it's a head you know
it's a head yeah it's a head yeah it's a head yeah it's a
head mm-hmm what what are what am i talking about what are
you talking about i'm talking about the the the headers that
are you doing yeah yeah but it was supposed to be on
saturday but um we have to rescape that's why my schedule is
late because we were trying to figure out the timing for the
announcement and stuff so finally i have it finalized i am
so excited me too i will finally talk about it usually with
a lot of vtuber stuff sometimes people are like okay
friendie friendie this yeah this one this one i don't i no
idea nobody has said a word nope i can only infer i
obviously won't be inferring here but i can only infer but
nobody has actually said a word yeah even mint doesn't know
mint asked me and i was just like okay you're gonna get me
they're gonna maybe yeah maybe allegedly sometimes my
friends and i have been like oh by the way i'm doing this
don't tell anybody yeah This was not one of those genuinely
I think like the stadium has like Equal amount of both like
English fans And Argentinian fans right now Usually like the
stadium will have like It's like obviously like very obvious
Which team has mature Oh shit Oh Oh Wait they passed it back
to the English The game Oh never mind Well and then the
English fumbled Oh that was such a good steal Oh but they
didn't got it back okay he can technically try and force a
corner oh what the fuck push him they're not gonna call it
oh my another oh and then they passed it back oh this is
actually crazy oh but like also don't notice we're no longer
pushing oh never mind nope nope foul i was gonna say they're
no longer pushing yeah referee left his cards in the locker
room he's like he'll be like i wonder if they know if i
didn't bring my cards yeah i sure hope they don't push each
other because i sure Dude, the fact that no yellow cards has
been called at all, not a single yellow card.
Ooh, you got a...
Oh, yeah, what was it?
Oh, there was apparently an MMA fight earlier this week.
And then what was the guy's name?
Connor McGregor, right?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and then he broke it.
He got hurt right before it.
like the first this is what we're getting instead this was
the actual fight they're like no we need some aggressive
energy yeah yeah they're just don't worry god oh good head
come on come on one more head one more head oh my god it's
pink ball big head big head big head oh wait that's actually
an insane defense it was just from i didn't see this at a
big head yeah he tore his acl in the first kick so then
world cup was like don't worry we got you we got you brother
we got you
oh messi's on the ground they're like they're like arcading
oh my god that yellow card does exist that wait who got it
who got who wait who got it who is he giving the card to i
don't know there's all they're all pushing they're all
touching and pushing anymore he's like yellow card yellow
card see i do have cards he i do have cards guys look look
yellow card is yellow that is wild i wonder how many people
had bet that there was going to be a lot of pushing this
game and they lost money remember kids you should not be
betting money everyone gets
What the fuck is like, get him, he's still running.
Holy shit, Dal, he's like, what happened?
The city is so confused.
Okay, no, that actually, no, that, that, that actually, that
was literally like, like a gang fight.
Like, they actually jumped him.
They, they were not very nice to him.
I felt like 20 people just jumped this man in an alleyway.
Even he got up and he's like, guys, what the fuck, guys?
He's like, I'm just, I'm just, I'm just, look, he looks so
confused, poor messy.
Yeah, that wasn't so messy.
That, he should have chosen that, that was actually, no,
that yellow was actually deserved.
Everybody, okay, you can push everybody, but you don't push
messy.
If you push messy, you know, oh, same thing with Halon's
boyfriend.
If you push Halon's boyfriend, there he is.
Oh my gosh.
What is he praying for?
Wait, that's so funny.
He's like, please, please, God, please.
Wait, did he touch it?
Oh, no, it hit him.
Praying to the ref is such a reminder to me of like all the
boys in school when they played this and then something
happened.
Oh, come on.
Because like the ball grazed one of the English players.
Yeah, no, it balled.
So they're like, please, come on.
You saw that ref.
You saw it.
It touched him.
It touched him last.
And the rep is like, I do not see.
I do not have a card.
I know nothing.
Speaking of knowing nothing, I got some white wine in the
fridge.
I bought it for today.
Oh, grab that.
Grab that.
No, I'm letting it get colder.
It is South American white wine, though.
No, sorry, South African, not South American.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No, South Africa is gone from the World Cup.
I know, but I didn't want to be like, you know, picking
sides with my alcohol today, since I'm already picking sides
with my...
But you're already picking a side.
Yeah, I was like, matter sometimes you know you got to be oh
you should grab it for second half that's when it gets real
crazy cool oh man come on let's score some fucking guys
cause i'm fucking go sorry score some fucking guys boy you
bloody blend me mom's from Plymouth that's right have you
ever watched The peaky blinders.
The what flat?
Clearly, it happens.
No, me neither.
It's like a TV show with Killian Murphy.
Oh, the open eye guy.
They're like, yeah, the whole time they're like, Oi, buy the
order of the peaky fucking blinders.
That's kind of like the whole, every time I see a clip of it
on TikTok, they're like, buy the order of the peaky
blinders.
And then they just like shoot each other.
But it's like the baby guns from like the early 1900s.
So they're like, pew.
ow, what pang, you know, it's like a little bit slow.
This has honestly been the most entertaining game so far out
of all the games I've watched.
Yeah, I'm glad that this is for you.
You're lucky that this is their first game.
I had to watch some really, really bad games.
Yeah, just a few frogs, as they say.
This game is fucking wild.
I'm like anticipating the next tackle right now.
You're like bracing yourself?
Yeah, I'm like, oh, I guess who's next?
Who's next?
The fact that no one has gotten injured, too, is crazy.
Hey, the night is young.
It's like not entertaining in terms of like the football
they're playing.
It's literally entertaining by just, this is just like
wrestling right now.
It really is just wrestling.
Yeah, I'm waiting for that.
I would be very surprised if no red card is pulled for this
game.
To be fair, a lot of these fouls could have been a yellow
card, but it's been yeah crazy.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm just waiting for the ref to start playing, too.
The ref comes and starts pushing.
Oh, my God, wait, what happened?
What happened?
I also missed it.
Oh, he grabbed the shirt.
Oh, that, he grabbed the shirt.
Who shirt did he grab?
Okay.
Oh, yeah, no, yeah, he did.
Yes.
He was grabbing a good drillian shirt.
Yeah, I was going to say it.
now it's equalized the paycheck came through guys the key i
wonder if um the transfer went through they just like were
kind of giving them a false sense of security like yeah
don't worry guys start pushing start kicking we won't do
anything i'm like ha ha you fell for a master plan he's like
he was like the rep was like wait pulling the other car was
so fun maybe i should do that again i have the power he's
just like wait a minute wait yeah i should do this more
often yeah he finally found his cards and now he started
he's starting pulling them so anyway i started blasting yeah
he's like wait a minute kind of vibes i found them it's all
right guys i got the cards you just need to find the red
ones oh yeah so if another player if the same player gets a
second yellow card it's an automatic red card and when a
player gets a red cart they're literally they have to play
with one yeah they have to play with one less player they
can't even someone in oh shit oh fell that guy pushed him
that's fucking pushed and he fell on the oh my god felon you
should have stayed on the ground he should have stayed on
the you know i can't believe it is no i had to do recording
yesterday so yeah you're off me too it's really bad mint
freaking sent me vocals for one of our songs and she just
she's like i'm working on the song an hour later send me all
the vocals and the arms and i'm like you wait is that
wonderful wait original are you spoiling something oh no i
literally didn't show them no i yesterday showed the mince
vocals i'm like guys i'm so angry at this stinky freaking
girl she's like i'm gonna work on the vocals sits down
perfectly beautiful vocals amazing so cute hitting the high
notes so cleanly and i'm here like yeah she's a professional
i got into vtubing not just v i got into streaming because i
didn't want to work you guys turn on streams like i don't
know what i'm doing today I got into streaming because I was
like, I don't want to work.
I just want to game.
And now I'm here being like, all right, 15 or more projects,
you know?
Oh, honestly, same.
It's so hard to balance everything.
I know.
I feel bad.
I just tell myself that, like, what do you feel bad about?
I feel bad because, you know, I feel like, oh, if I had put
more time or effort into something like this, but there's so
many stuff to do that you have to sacrifice one for the
other.
And I've had to learn sometimes that it's like, it's bad.
to just get it out instead of trying to make it perfect like
it's just i'm still really bad with that i'm still even
sometimes like when like plants fall through too with
streams you're just like i'd just rather go live and hang
out than like oh it wasn't what i planned etc etc you know
but one of the reasons i try to keep busy with other work is
so that way i can then stream for like eight hours and
disassociate you know yeah oh at least that one wasn't have
found none of these are fouls oh yeah oh wait three minutes
they're adding three minutes only three oh i mean they
aren't that's wow only three minutes including this they
literally just only added the hydration break yep because
like that that should have been like i don't know it should
have been like five or six minutes i do have a weird
conspiracy of like are they just trying to you know make the
game longer because they're they're making the game shorter
right now right now because usually uh additional time it's
uh uh it's like you have to add in the hydration break
because the clock is still running and then usually with all
the fouls it would be like adding like maybe two or three
more minutes so the average is like five five to six minutes
so it being three minutes is legitimately really shocking
and yeah i love doki pro i love it she knows everything i
learned through twitter i also used that and i was like you
know chat educated me with some of the rules because like i
used to play soccer back then so i like everything i learned
about is just me from playing the game but then there's like
rules that are exclusively just in the world cup that they
don't have like if you're playing a backyard game your dad's
yelling at a guy punching him you're like well i'm not
allowed to punch a guy Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a little bit different, you know?
Oh, oh, they're stalling.
So right now, England is stalling the ball right now.
England!
Oh, you bloody villains!
Oh, oh, good pass!
Good pass because it led to a foul.
Good pass.
Oh, it's offside.
Never mind.
Bad pass.
Bad pass!
Bad!
His dick was too big, so it triggered offside.
I don't think you know offside rules, but you're not allowed
to cross the specific line When the goal is being passed
towards you So the keeper can have like so So it prevents
people Yes, it prevents like spawn camping Spawn camping
Yeah, the goalie basically Yeah, you don't want to need a
spawn camp Oh shit, no foul!
Keep playing!
He didn't see He didn't like that razor has like sir that's
a foul the guys he blinked he couldn't see it it happened so
fast he was blinking a genuine question for the people in
the chat the guy was like come on why won't they just have
more referees to see more of the field because they'll crowd
the field like there's already a lot of people on the field
and they don't want like the ref to start blocking shots
because you know they have to pass what the ref is literally
blocking certain areas like isn't the rep like sit on top of
a high chair like a like a lifeguard and have binoculars
like it's tennis like the wimbledon yeah genuinely that's
like the rep's never stupid okay don't say i don't know
budget maybe they're making there's so much money each game
is like each ticket for the world cup is crazy expensive
depending on which day you're watching they definitely have
money to put a guy with binoculars you know like for the
finals one vip ticket is like thirty thousand dollars and
you can still buy them hey everybody buy the merch buy the
merch you must buy the merch dokey bird merch matara con dot
zero zero wait is the three minutes already there's no way
send us to the next world cup it's in half time no they're
still arguing through oh my god they're still arguing from
the half time started honestly this makes me realize i can
be worse i don't argue in off i don't cause enough trouble
in my day-to-day life yeah i could be so much worse this is
great that's crazy today is actually like watching hockey i
don't actually hockey i i do not care about hockey i i like
watching it every time i have the chance to be in montreal
if there's ever a hockey game i always try to go i always
try to get like cheap nosebleed seats because it's just
everybody's yelling and everyone's drinking beer yeah it
doesn't matter what happens that's where all the riots come
from no the only reason i don't watch hockey i talked about
this before for those you're like faking it's like i don't
like to watch sports i'm bad at and i'm really bad at ice
skating so i just don't care if i'm bad at a sport if i'm so
you're telling me you're good at footy yeah yeah i used to
be in the varsity team for middle to high school and i've
won like i've MVPs and stuff.
That's crazy, girl.
Yeah, I can't even walk straight.
I can't even walk straight.
I just have really good hand-eye coordination.
So that's why I translate really well to gaming.
Because, like, it's literally all that.
Also, I need to walk my dog.
Can you entertain chat?
I'll be right back, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me see.
All right, everybody.
Let me teach you British swear words.
No, I'm kidding.
Hello, everybody.
It's just us.
I am Matara Khan.
Please go on to dokeymerch.com.
if you already bought your dog shirt then um you may gift
doki some gifted members as a thank you for her for doing
this um thank you for her for inviting me we kind of talked
about it very briefly and then i was like hey can i actually
still come and she's like y'all so here i am um hold on let
me mute these ads no offense to these ads but it's one of
those things because the ads are playing i i can't like hear
you you know in chat very well like i read everything in
your little voice like buy another dog shirt doki has too
many dog shirts you know buy her dog a shirt buy your dog a
shirt do you know how many dog shirts she bought um no but
she alluded on my podcast that it's um too many and i told
her by the way okay i'm gonna tell you this some of you
don't haven't seen the podcast episode with doki that's fine
uh in an hour's time with
guess was Doki, promo.
She actually talked about how she bought too many shirts and
I told her what she needs to do is she needs to make the
long dragoon.
You know how she has like the little chubby short dragoon.
She has like all these little types of dragoons.
She needs to make a long neck dragoon plushy, the exact same
size as a little dog would be.
And she has to sell him in a bundle with the dog shirt.
Love the episode.
Thank you, Fugles.
It's good to see you.
has to do it you saw it on the patreon oh true fan true fan
let's go oh thank you oh my god everybody in an hour's time
with matara um but yes uh oh oh oh they're back on they're
back on but i think it's just the highlights it's just the
highlights they're back on they're just showing how much
they're like hugging and kissing on the on the field but yes
i think she needs to do a long dragoon plushie and bundle it
with the shirt and and you might be like matara are you
telling us she's to sell the shirt yes that's what they do
with the marvel movies sorry to you know they did the batman
movies to sell the toys to sell the batman toys that was a
big problem for mr um george cloney george cloney he was
like what do you mean i have to be campy for you guys to
sell toys but it was the truth wolf thank you for the
gifting thank you thank you thank you yeah you can you can
papa you can dokey and i okay so i actually had to cut it
off because we actually went you even longer on the side,
but I'm going to get her in again.
It's going to be some good times.
So yeah, I hate to break it to y'all.
I hate to break it to y'all, but basically they make a lot
of movies to sell toys.
So I told Doki Bird, hey, make a long Dragoon plushie,
bundle it with, am I rooting for England or Argentina?
Look at my forehead.
Tell me what it tells you I'm rooting for.
and what the hell is on the torres head this is where i grew
up i'm not kidding the last time i watched football was 20
years ago it was the 2006 fifa cup uh yeah i'm rooting for
argentina because i'm a little bit of a contrarian and also
as you know is ukraine in the in the european union no but
ukraine does get invited to eurovision so as a eurovision
fan you never ever ever root for England nobody roots for
England so it's just ingrained in my blood I just I can't
help it
it just kind of sticks with me you know I can't help it
what's up tuner I'm kind of distantly related some might
call me Eastern European but you know Eurovision exactly I'm
rooting against England kind of like that yeah Doki's
outside buying fish and chips
I kind of don't mind.
I'm not cheering very, um, seriously, to be honest.
I'm here for the good vibes.
And this is very good vibes.
Oh my God.
For anybody that doesn't watch, they kept tackling each
other.
They kept hugging.
Oh my God.
And they would zoom in on their legs and their legs have so
many muskles.
Wow.
If I had one comment, I would make their shorts shorter and
their, and their tank tops more.
Like see, they pull each other by the sleeves.
You know what would if you gave them tight skin tight tank
tops they couldn't be pulling on them then i'm just saying
sorry but it's true don't get shy it's true if they had no
sleeves and like really tight on the abdominals they
couldn't pull them also yes every time they have a yolo card
they have to kiss no that doesn't really do it for me
v-cuber i'm supposed to be like wow yoi but women kissing or
men kissing doesn't really do it for me even couples kissing
i'm like god i wish that was me the only thing that does it
for me is me kissing so yeah sorry i'm like letting my
inhibitions run wild um no i think maybe like having them
hug would be nice maybe like zooming in on their big muscles
when they hug or like if they do like a handshake and then
you see like their muscles when they handshake you know oh
my god oh my god yellow card they have to take off their
t-shirt
whoo joki is a retired food joe probably probably i don't
know i've um i've talked about it before my by the way for
everybody the game is not back on yet they're just kind of
talking it's half time you know half show um so that's why
talking over it because it's you know coca-cola half time so
um yeah i feel like a lot of youtubers are very into like
yuri or yaoi and again all props to you you watch whatever
you want on off the internet i am not here to judge um no
i've talked about it before mint um sorry to call out mint
here but she she listens to like raunchy audiobooks on her
day-to-day and one time i talked to amalie years ago in a
collab and she recommended this book series to me called the
court of thorn and roses oh my god it's a canadian ad
dokey's missing the canadian advertisements stop wait one
second you guys are gonna have to wait for the story i gotta
tell her it's a goose
oh my god dokey dokey's missing the canadian ad stop dokey
bird canada needs you
oh dokey canada needs you okay back to back to the pit so um
hey thank you for the soup a our spa where were we in my
very interesting story that you're very interested by.
Okay, keep listening.
So Amalie ages ago recommended me this book called The Court
of Thorn and Roses.
She said it's a fantasy book.
So I am in public reading this book, okay?
It starts off, okay.
I'm not gonna spoil it for you, but I don't like books where
it's like very teenage in the sense of this girl is like, I
hunt and I kill these animals to take care of my no good
family while my sisters bully me and my dad is sick.
I'm the one taking care of everybody and they don't even
love and respect me and it's like girl just leave them if
you're the hunter gatherer and you're so good like why are
you putting up with these losers right like take your dad
and just leave them tell your sisters if you don't start
being nice to me I'm not giving you this whatever dear
tallow you know um but anyway long story short it goes
exactly as you expect sexy guy enemy to lovers whatever sexy
demon man 8,000 years old whatever.
And then I'm in public reading this book.
And then they start doing it.
Like, I think like 10 pages before the end of the first
book, spoiler alert, they start going at it.
Like, truly, they start doing it.
And I'm in public.
And I just, I, I get, I start blushing.
I start looking around.
And then it hits me.
I'm like, every single person who has seen me read this book
in public is like, yeah.
you fucking pervert look at you reading this book in public
8 000 is a bit of an age gap okay i have a rule i don't
really care about that stuff frankly past the age of 25 do
whatever you want if you're 25 and you're with an 80 year
old who am i to judge yeah if you're like 15 it's oh you
know that's different but if you're over the age of if
you're over the age of 30 do what you want to do but i need
you all to know that you all need to keep the same energy
with me when i'm 125 do Do not judge me when I have my new
hot 35 year old or, you know, do not judge me when I'm cryo
cybernetically enhanced.
Oh, she's missing David Beckham.
No, we have to, okay.
We have to make up a lie about David Beckham.
We have to be like, oh my God, David Beckham was on screen
and then he punched his son and then him and Victoria
kissed.
We have to make up like a crazy story, okay, for when she's
back.
So she really feels the FOMO.
um but yeah so again my only thing with these like sexy
audio books or sexy books is after reading that book I just
remember thinking oh my god every single person that I have
crossed paths with who knows what this book is thinks I'm a
disgusting pervert which is fine and fair and they're
totally allowed to but I don't want them thinking that and
same thing for mint I have to tell you this story about
Mind.
She was telling me that she's reading Minotaur or she was
like listening to Minotaur milking farms, exactly what it
sounds like.
And she's like, oh, I'm going to shower and listen or like
I'm going to sleep and listen to the book.
And I kind of made a joke of like, ha ha, sleep, ha.
That's all you're going to do.
You're just going to sleep, winky face and listen to the
book, nothing else.
And she was like, Matara, what the fuck is wrong with you,
you fucking pervert?
I'm like, I am the pervert for insinuating that you're gonna
maybe like while you're listening to like i'm the pervert
for insinuating that maybe you know you're gonna be like a
little silly and freaky listening to a freaky book i am the
one that's the pervert for insinuating that how is this how
is this real how is this the real life that she's like ew
matara what is wrong like what she's no i'm just listening
to it because it's funny i'm like i don't understand So
anyway, this whole speech to let you know that I, Yawui
Yudi, not really for me.
No, Judgey, he's just not really for me.
I genuinely get like a little shy in public with that stuff.
And I even told Amali about this.
I'm like, Amali, people saw me read this in public spaces.
And they probably were like, yeah, you pervert.
You're waiting for that 8,000 year age gap.
where they have the coitus aren't you i wasn't i didn't know
okay so here's our story when she comes back they showed
david beckham for like 10 minutes they showed david beckham
for like 10 minutes five minutes she won't believe 10 but
she'll believe five i feel like she'll believe five they
kept showing david beckham they did not stop doing i'm back
hello i'm girl you miss david That's why she's listening to
Minotaur milking farms.
What's the context was that?
Are you talking about mint?
Is that?
Because they said that you're a retired.
They said that you're a retired Fujio.
I am.
I'm retired.
I'm reformed.
No, no, I'm retired.
I no longer, I no longer proud the archive of our own.
That's, I'm reformed, guys.
What reformed you?
When was it that you're like, okay i cannot be do it like
what was the smut that took you over the edge so you're like
no no this is disgusting it's when i uh it's when i went
corporal so i had no more time or were you like oh my god i
had no more time
also i told him about the dragoon i want you to make a long
goon and bundle it with the dog shirt and they love it they
love that idea yeah yeah i told him about the idea like this
is how we can sell more yeah it's like build a goon i get i
pitched i was like pitching it to them it's like build a
goon but also think about like in the batman movie right
like they made the batman movies to sell the toys which yeah
was like what do you mean you're doing this just to sell
toys i mean that's the whole point of like animation and tv
shows too based off of like uh uh popular you just are you
too much to sell dog shirts you harlot i maybe my dream was
a dog shirt designing i wanted to be i wanted to be gucci
for dogs and i fucked up um but you seriously missed like 10
minutes of date oh my god oh my god he's like showing off
his bloody little leg you want i love it oh my god this is
great i was saying i really wish that like why is it you
know how they keep grabbing each other's shirt yeah i wish
that they so one way that you can solve it is by giving them
tight tank tops right with no sleeves and then when they get
a yellow card they have to take off their tank top so it's
like strip soccer is it if it's a red card you gotta play
naked oh we start oh wait that's no you got we can't play
anymore you gotta yeah take out your clothes and then get
off the field and then get off the no it's fine try to just
leave the field but what did the countdown again what i love
that that guy like he just keeps showing off his little legs
they're not little they're very long wait why do we have to
do the countdown again what happened i don't know they're
like we gotta do the cat there's like so many people i'm
telling you back they just showed david beckham for like 10
minutes what was he doing was there was victoria there his
wife was there and the people behind them she was just not
oh my god i have restart this entire thing that he oh my rev
you fucked it up for me i'm gonna say it up for you um i
forgot to reset the the timer thing okay oh my i forgot
again okay there you go i got it missed a canadian
superstore ad as well oh no i can't believe i missed an ad
oh no all right what are they doing oh there was a field
invasion Oh, someone ran on the field or some shit.
Someone said that someone said there was something like on
the field that happened.
So they had to like usually when there's streakers or
someone like Invading the field, there was a streaker and I
missed it.
But usually you don't know because the cameras will
instantly cut out cut off.
So you don't want to encourage people to run on the field.
It's like, you know, it's like, what's it called swatting?
Usually people don't tell usually people don't tell if
they're getting swatted because they'll encourage to.
or slotting.
Yeah.
So it's like, it's basically those type, those type of
rules.
Pitch forward.
Who the fuck is pitch forward?
Oh, that's the goalie.
Darn.
That is like, fake fan.
I just, everyone just knows like the, like the, the, the
A-listers, like Kane, Bellingham, Messy.
Exactly.
Well, the thing is, I don't even know the, number mess he's
wearing i just know he's on the field there somewhere he's
lucky number seven wait i think he is seven oh shit oh good
oh my god that's an insane save this if he had a follow-up
the goalie would have been oh my god what the fuck again oh
it's 10 who's seven who's seven there's someone that's seven
but i don't remember who it is i'm gonna write there's
pitchfork there he is Let's go pitchfork Oh Ronaldo a seven
It's always kind of interesting to know like the
significance of their Because like they get to pick their
numbers as long as like the numbers not claimed yet So
there's always like a significance to like whatever number
they have I do know that there are some numbers where it's
like just the greats So they're like oh I can't have this
number and you know like one day one day someone's gonna
pick 67
There's going to be a famous football player with the number
67.
There's got it already in 10 years.
Oh, is it based on positions?
Oh, okay.
I guess that's like the professional.
If you could pick a number.
Well, when you're doing like school football, you get to
pick your number.
So I thought I picked, I had one time I had zero and then
the other time I had one because like goalkeeper at one and
and zero if i could pick a number i'd want to be four that's
my lucky number oh that's an unlucky number in asian
cultures i know but i'm february four what the fuck holy
shit they those so hard okay i don't know how to tell you
this you met me at a very un-chinese time in my life why how
so because i'm not chinese oh you're right i don't think
you'll He's having your life.
Unless, I don't know, unless you go through your family tree
and then found one Chinese ancestor at least.
Well, they're, um, they did make those like really great
Soviet posters of like, um, that's what I like to hear.
Great egg Soviet.
I'm in the same sense.
No, it was like this.
Oh my God.
Let me show you the best part about the Soviet Union guys.
The post.
Everybody knows what I'm talking about.
They look like two gay dads.
They make promaganda posters of like...
Let me show you.
They're called like the Gay Dads posters.
They're great.
Yeah, Matara's getting nostalgic about the Soviet Union.
I am!
How often do you think about the Soviet Union?
For a lot of people, they don't want to think about the
Soviet Union.
This literally means friendship for decades.
Not for decades, for centuries.
Oh!
Don't they look like gay dads?
like tell me this isn't like your your two gay dads they're
just really really good friends some would say roommates
guys yeah they're saying um made forever reformed fujo uh be
honest as a reformed fujo this slaps doesn't it yeah they
look like they're roommates really really good friends that
live together oh hey thanks jesus jesus also loves the seno
soviet yowie posters i know jesus is not reformed oh oh good
head good head it got oh foul come on what great head i like
how when there's no foul they just get back in get it back
up instantly oh that would have been insane christopher just
like the acting didn't pay off you should have stayed on the
ground maybe eventually he'll call the file got a yeah it
was a slow burn let's go oh nice okay not Wait, not nice,
not nice.
There's a Argentinian guy right there.
Oh, well, it's okay.
He still got it.
Oh, it's at Berlin Am.
Okay, that's a...
Yeah!
Wait.
He brought his yellow cards this time.
Because he touched him.
Oh, what the fuck?
He's like caressing him.
He's just like, I love you, bro.
I love you.
That is not just a touch.
oh that is that every time we touch i get this that's crazy
because every time we touch i get this
oh he definitely felt his heartbeat fast though during that
that was full contact good head full contact what else is a
girl to ask i love watching wrestling guys this was a good
wrestling match people are saying you're sounding very
reformed i'm gonna tweak that this is the best wrestling
match in world cup because every time we touch oh i gotta
pee soon next time they do a little break i'm gonna pee and
get my wall you should yeah for the hydration break yeah i
gotta hydrate
reformed fujo by the way
he really he really they fall so dramatically i love it yeah
but then if you dive too hard you can get yellow card if
it's like a full-on uh like someone got kicked uh during the
switzerland argentina game um a player got a red card
because they got two yellow cards uh because one of the
yellow cards they dove and it oh he touched me wow cooties
he was just like Oh my god, I got kudies.
I
He's like, ah, gross.
Doki, by the way, you got a pink supra.
Oh, I do.
I'm one of my peep.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the pink soup.
Magenta supra.
Chris, thank you.
Thank you.
It's worth even more.
He's enjoying.
I know if he's Norwegian, which team is he cheering for?
Because England can't go out.
Oh my god, it's Norwegian money.
England kicked out Norway oh who you cheering for Chris no
judges hot potato are you that's a good pass boyfriend I
mean Holland would want you to cheer for him yeah don't
don't don't don't don't don't
so I'm just yeah having a random question for the audience
while you're chilling yeah um how many I'm locked dog shirts
do you guys own not enough donkey bird true fan i'm just
wondering like how many there he is that's the guy that's
the guy that's the guy that's the guy that owns fifa
everyone hates him too fair what ceo is beloved though oh
other than gabe otherwise seems the moment gabe's dead see i
like the ceo of gigacorp Oh, yeah, oh, okay, but like
they're not but not via like friends.
You have no biases towards Oh damn, no nepotism bias no
friendship.
Oh Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Is that the leg guy?
Is that the guy who's showing off his leg?
Yeah, that was the guy showing off his leg.
Coming home, it's coming home, it's coming home.
Football's coming home, it's coming home, it's coming home.
It's coming, oh, she's happy.
Guys, guys, she can smile.
She can, she can smile.
It's like, good job, son, you did it.
That's like, she thought like he was the one that scored.
He's like, good shot.
Oh my, that's a crazy shot.
That's actually, wait, was that assisted by Bellingham too?
Oh my god, and it's a Bellingham assist.
She has mouth muscles.
She has, oh my god, that's crazy.
I'm showing off his leg.
What's like a bug?
Oh my god, it worked.
That's actually, oh, Messi's just like, fuck.
But boss coming home, it's coming home, it's coming home.
Oh, there's a lot, wait, where's the third line?
Did they eat him?
where's the third lion what happened to him the random
english player i decided was my favorite player on the team
actually made a play right dude for me it's just like the
legs he was mesmerizing me maybe they were distracted they
were like damn look at those glutes nice legs poppy got
hungry after they're watching the game i guess it would be
poppy it would be Wait, a lot.
Oh no, Argentina has activated the VARD card.
England, you've stumbled onto a trap card.
Activate VAR.
So VAR is like what they do now for World Cup where it's
like they have like extra cameras around the field and they
have extra referees in a little room called the VAR room
that like that like basically I guess like, oh, what's the
word?
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Oh, I thought he was going to score again.
But that surveillance.
Yeah, that surveillance everything.
You're activating extra eye.
So video assisted replay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that is that not a foul?
Is that not a foul?
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, they're like, why did you do that, bro?
I don't even know if he's doing that as in like good job or
like why the fuck?
I thought it was a good job.
That's a penalty kick, though.
a penalty kick oh that's the thing that's a yeah i wasn't no
happier i can't tell i can't tell they're like good job no
it's a court yeah it was a perfect tackle oh my god great
because he like hit the ball him yeah and he was going
straight for the goal that's i'll be honest it's no foul the
fact that it's not foul is crazy it's because if you tackle
and you hit the ball first it's not considered a foul.
Oh, so he did good.
Yeah, yeah, he touched the, I couldn't tell the replay was
so fast.
I didn't, again, I wasn't sure.
I should be looking at the feet, but I was too distracted by
the body contact.
Not to be, ooh, not to be like that, but I was like, you
know how it's like, are you mad at me?
I can't tell.
I can't, and then like, and then the teammates were like
pushing him and everything, but I didn't know if it was a
good or bad push.
You're like, are you guys good pushing or bad pushing?
Yeah.
Are you, are you happy with this or are you unhappy?
Yeah, because if he fucked up that tackle, would be on the
penalty kick because it happened in the box
that was going in so even if it was a penalty it was worth
it hey i mean that definitely seemed like yeah yeah because
then he would have a second yeah oh nice oh my god did he
touch it he's like damn it i think it's a corner kick it's
like because he touched it or something let's
see really oh oh yeah that's so yeah oh my gosh she's so
happy she's like you did no victoria's like you did it babe
you did it for england i do wonder if it's like the memes of
her not giving a when viral so now she's like look guys yeah
i do care just in case the camera's on oh my god that was so
risky from the goalkeeper that was old oh argent oh oh my
god oh oh oh he fumbled he hesitated he hesitated if he just
took the shot right now i think it went in he was he got he
got overwhelmed there's like 80 people on the field right
now england called in england called in the fans to come
into the court like come into the field there's like 20
people now playing
hesitation is defeat well said where is my haramba haramba
come on don't you have just haramba
oh good head well actually that's mediocre head yeah because
it went back to the uh enemy team hold on i'm testing some
buttons why are you testing i'm testing some buttons don't
worry about it don't worry about it no i can't buy you
gifted members because my paypal country is different from
my payments profile country i'm in america so i can't use my
oh oh nice oh oh oh the fans couldn't get the ball i wonder
how much those balls are not like baseball you like you a
cell like it would catch a whole line or whatever probably
so have a sign but then how would people be able to prove
because you can just like grab another ball right no these
are there's like um each of those balls have like uh a
number no no they have like uh sensors on in them so it
could detect if something touched like interfered or touch
it but which conveniently was off at during one time but we
don't talk about that part yeah that was that was but like
but like basically even a hair strand on the ball oh my god
jesus coming and clutch with a five get jesus got you jesus
christ chips i am sorry that you were hung you mean like
nailed on the cross yeah you was hung um jesus was hung um
um on the cross right yeah
England what are you doing when I said it's coming home I
don't mean take them he was crucified not hung he could have
also been hung you don't know that
Marcia thank you for five gifted ships thank you thank you
uh Tom if you don't give the ships thank you have a dog
shirt give Doki some subs if you give me more Each dog is
equal.
But you have to get a grave subscription for this.
So I can make more dog shirts.
It's true.
You should then make dog shirts for different dolls.
Oh, no, make more shirts.
Yeah, make more shirts for you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to open build a goon.
Make a dog shirt for your little dokey plush.
I should have a, I should have a dad plush.
So you can put the shirt on the dad.
if you don't oh my god wait that's actually genius i just
keep making plushies so you can buy dog shirts for it
exactly if you think about it you're literally creating the
problem and the solution it's like when they were like
exactly and then i now finally run out of shirts and then
all the plushies will be naked and then no and then i have
to order more dog shirts so then the plushies can have
clothes and then it's like a cycle it's like a cycle i just
never end the dog shirts just
you do and the supply see guys the industrial era never
stops no i look like i truly do look like the the symbol of
capitalism right now you're being very british i am i am i'm
in the british time right now oh shit what's going on why
are they still playing the whistle was called hey guys um
the whistle was called i don't know why you're still here my
manager just put his foot down after hearing that says no
more dog shirts you can't stop me i pay you
by the way i've said this but my mom took the really nice
chanel hand cream lotion that you gave me oh i saw that in
the clip payment for for helping me and i'm like but i pay
you for helping me i i literally pay you for helping me what
do you mean this is payment for helping me Christmas bonus,
you know?
But I pay you for helping me.
What's going on?
But, but, but I just want your manager to like realistically
doing a dog plus for a long dragoon plus.
She's pitching right now.
I'm pitching.
I think it's a great idea and you bundle them.
She's enabling me.
She's enabling me and I'm allowing it.
I just, I just think, you know, you, you understand good
ideas.
Exactly.
i've always had good ideas including making a lot of dog
shirts no oh oh what a oh that defense was crazy what the
okay what's that he's like quarter quarter yeah that's a
corner kick i want to go pee but i'm scared they're gonna
pug and tackle you know the fact that there's no hydration
oh my That was a really good for tech.
That's insane defense right there.
He's like, goink, my ball.
He has better health than the other guy.
Hey, he's got good head.
He has experience.
You can tell that he has a lot of head experience.
Because he scored the first goal.
I don't think he's going to have to worry about head for any
time, anytime soon in his life as a professional.
Because he's so good at it, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, we're talking about heads.
guys we're talking about headers oh now now you're just the
first time i saw what it was like on the other side after 20
years they had to get the argentina goalie back into the
cage oh he's like he's like come on let's go of the ball
come on you know you want to let go no foul no foul yeah
yeah he's just sleeping oh look he got back up that's
fucking right bro he got back up i know you're acting no i
wonder how long they act into the like okay i actually got
to get back into the game they're not stopping this for my
acting did he pull him outside i think it's like the moment
like the ref usually gives a hand signal when he's like no
foul like he just gives like he just no yeah so then that's
not all of his buddy i mean both countries have really good
actors one has soap operas the other has baptas hey oh
corner kick i don't know if that was after they're back in
the middle when when is the hydration break i don't know the
rep calls that randomly usually it happens like it should
have happened a little earlier but you know what please get
a hydration break i want to pee and to get my wine i want to
get some sparkling water wait until maybe in like 10 minutes
maybe i'm gonna piss myself uh in minecraft guys in
minecraft in my uh in my as a child oh yeah yeah yeah true
true true true guys uh we are not enabling oh oh good head
good head great head i'm gonna start i'm gonna start using
that in my day-to-day like that was some really bad just
like that like randomly oh oh nice another corner kick i
feel like we've been on oh rt has been like super aggressive
right now that we have never left we said it's coming home
and they are actually coming to england oh coming to england
right now the messy drum no i'm i'm honestly scared to away
it's one zero because like okay i know yeah i'm scared to
look away because they're getting like they're oh oh my god
oh my god oh that's it that's yeah yeah oh but then we had
one guy just one guy out there what are you doing there what
are you doing to get back in oh now you're getting back in
why are you running why are you here oh oh oh what a save
that's a crazy save that's a
It's pitchfork.
Raise your pitchforks.
He wants hydration break.
He's calling for it.
Please, please.
Yes.
Okay.
That's a crazy save.
The man, the legend.
Scott Sterling.
Oh, that was, yeah.
He was like in the line too.
Oh my gosh.
Hydration break.
All right, go get your wine.
All right.
Yeah, that was a crazy save.
That literally might just be Scott Sterling right there.
Yeah, that break was so crazy.
He was like, I need a timeout to process what happened.
Oh, there's the third lion.
There he is.
He came back.
That guy actually missed the goal.
I can't believe it.
This is a...
There's been a lot of insane goalkeepers during this World
Cup, I will say.
Yeah, he's not dead.
He came back and got British citizenship.
who doesn't know scott sterling not only is he a great
baller in soccer he's a great baller in volleyball i think
the volleyball one is a lot is you guys haven't watched the
volleyball one that one is a great sequel to scott sterling
only because the casters the casters leveled up
far i'll show you guys for those who never watch scott
sterling let me show you guys a youtube video i won't show
it but let me link it to you scott sterling the man the
legend scott sterling all right this is a classic the
greatest goalkeeper in history and i can't believe america
did not draft him into a world cup i think that was was a
snub right there hello welcome back we're still i bought a
good time it's the odds yeah it's still the ads it's it's
ted lasso this is where uh holland become if holland never
becomes a football player he turns in he goes to uber oh i
thought he was into cooking he is i saw like his cooking
videos i like my algorithm is just all football now yep Oh,
is that Poulay Rouge?
Oh, my God.
It is the best fast food every time.
Do you guys have it on your end of Canada?
It's just like a chicken place that does the best.
Like you get a chicken salad or a rice and chicken.
It's the best.
Oh, I love it.
I've never heard of it before.
So good.
It might be more of a Quebec thing then.
I think so.
Maybe.
I know they have them in Toronto, but.
My manager just like messaged me.
And apparently my schedule got age restricted.
what as a oh my god did you put a sexy photo i don't know
why did it get age restricted sorry dokey can i see the
photo you use that's so funny paco's artwork look at i used
this on yeah paco sensei paco sensei is it because it was i
don't understand is it because the whale looks like a giant
boo maybe They think the whale looked like a giant-ass
boobs.
Can you not show me and my virginal and pure eyes this
heresy and monstrosity?
The whale looks kind of sus.
It looks like a giant boop with a giant nipple.
That's really funny that you got restricted.
I love it.
That's so funny.
Let me get...
They thought I was naked.
Naked, dokey.
That's what you get for hugging.
Okay, so I have with me Kumusha, roots, origin, homes.
Sauvignon Blanc by Timache Niamu Dauhar.
Kumusha in the Zimbabwean Shona language means either your
home, your roots, or your origins.
My journey is a constant pursuit of wines from vineyards
that represent and honor their origins.
Oh, do we have any Zimbabweans in this stream?
By the way, guys.
Yes.
We're talking, oh yeah, the thing that got age restricted
was Twitter, not YouTube.
So, Elon said, Mr. Musk thought it was a giant boob with
nipples.
So this means on the YouTube, they can go look at your one
giant boob.
You can look at it.
You can see the adult content.
All right.
Since they are on a hydration break, I want all of you to go
on a hydration break.
No, they're playing right now.
I know.
I'm not.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, they said that the collar that Slachi is wearing
looks like...
pointed nipples spiky nipples all right they really need a
human to review this i'm sorry they need a human to review
this i'm you know have some crazy shenanigans oh is that oh
okay i keep forgetting blue is uh because like they have
like so many different colored jerseys so they always swap
jersey colors i always oh oh that was so close he was too
short to hit the he was not you couldn't jump down coming
from you that's okay it's okay it's okay i was talking about
a different player coming from you those are some lethal
words look it's yeah i get the pass i get the pass because
i'm also short i get the short pass crazy words crazy words
i i have the
like um it's actually really bad to be tall for football
because you all that's a haul on because it's like um the
what was it i read about it uh but guys it wasn't even messy
that was a different player like i wonder if it's just like
easier to do feet tricks it's the same thing with like
gymnastics it's easier to like do feet tricks your body it's
easier to like control your limbs and stuff your legs have
less chance of getting bruised and hurt yeah it's just you
you can't be too tall for football because like there's a 17
oh oh oh what a save what he's just like he just high five
the ball holy he just gave the ball a high five that save
was crazy the possession rate that Argentina has has been
like 80% of the halftime.
They have had the ball a lot and they have not scored a lot.
I told you it's Scott Sterling!
I mean, if it does go to PK, I would love to see a PK from
these two.
Because both have them at... What's a PK?
Pound Slayer kill?
Yeah, player kill.
They start eliminating the players one by one.
Oh my god, good pass, good pass, good pass.
Yeah, the middle name is Pitch4.
The man, the myth, the legend.
Yeah, it's a death match.
They start having a death match.
Last man standing.
Yep.
What's it say?
Oh, yeah.
So parent, okay, so there's like, the thing is people are
worried.
There's a player in World Cup right now.
He's like 19, 17 or 18 or 19.
I don't know.
debut when he was he started his debut at 16 basically okay
um and his name he plays for spain his name is yamel um wow
he's 19 right now sorry i can't keep keep forgetting his age
because there's also a mexican player that's 17 um and he's
really really good um but people were worried about him
because he's he keeps growing he keeps getting taller yeah i
think like i think just having more body means like easier
to get hurt easier but then like think of somebody like
holland where if you push somebody on the field like that
like you're no longer a freaking you know oh he missed he
missed you're like a football player running people down but
like like american football you know with like holland's
build that's great yeah yeah like holland thing is about
holland his their strategy he needs like a team to work with
him because he's like he's like a lurker basically he
doesn't actually like run towards anything until like it's
his turn you have to pass it to him yeah yeah until you pass
it to find a place he will make a place for himself that's
the thing howlin is too big to push yeah yeah i wonder if
that's gonna change a little bit of i don't know the meta of
like having bigger players means they're harder to push
around you know but then but then he gets called on more
though that's the thing it's like uh double edge because he
got he got called like the reason why one the goal was
rescinded was because he pushed another player down but he
was like kind of like I didn't even push him that hard but
because he's such a big player because he's so big yeah
everybody can they'll just be like well yeah but look at you
yeah exactly yeah I'm gonna have a look at you
yeah Talon needs ball no ball no score for Holland yeah
and simply eat not eat the smaller ones i know right there's
no rules in fifa against that oh my god brilliant got the
ball oh bellingham come on allan's boyfriend oh good defense
good defense great defense good d good d great d yeah but he
tried to score he could have passed there there was no
reason why he's he's like get out friendly fire friendly he
was pushing him for momentum guys for momentum it's like uh
you know in the movies when like they like grab somebody and
put them in front of them as meat shield yeah yeah yeah yeah
for momentum yeah was that harry kane that pushed his
teammate i can't i remember what was harry kane's number i
just saw number eight
i believe we got a pulleil rouge i hope i hope first thing
i'm back in canada is i'm getting pulleil rouge it's so good
like i don't even cook i'm in canada i just get puré rouge
four like four times a day is it really that good it's
literally like okay they have like four different flavors
for the chicken it's a real marinated chicken really good
macros not everything you can get it with rice you can get a
poutine i usually do salad and you pick like your veggies on
it so i'll pick like hot peppers i'll pick tomatoes onions
it's awesome let me see if i have photos to send you it's
just so good and it's actually healthy and it's delicious
they grill it in front of you oh that sounds so good I just
don't think I have it here.
I don't think so.
I've never seen it on Uber.
I wonder if it's going to be like red chicken or something
because, you know, Poulay is, yeah.
The Roosh Poutine is so good.
I never get the Poutine because I'm an old woman.
She's Poutine now.
I need to transfer my calories for wine.
I do.
Oh, it's an East Coast.
Oh, oh, God.
Oh, the trick shot.
He's trying to do a trick shot.
He lined up for, yeah.
Yeah.
Harry stay on the ground.
Harry is a master of this, by the way.
He's known for being really, really good at staying on the
ground.
If it wasn't for football, I think he'd be a really good
actor.
Yeah.
Yeah, Cade, let's go.
Okay, Joki, I'm not going to lie.
I typed chicken in my phone and like the amount of chicken
feet and just like big ass rotisserie chickens I have saved
in photos is like, damn, what am I doing with my life?
we know what is going on with him he wasn't even involved
with anything why is he on the ground hey he's the one that
oh whoa that's why we when did this happen when i don't
remember this part
damn i haven't had rotisserie chicken a while i still
haven't ordered food football over food what did you want to
order your your fish and chips oh no i'm ordering i I
ordered food for whichever team wins.
Yeah.
What is it going to be?
Or are you only going to decide after they win?
After they win.
Anything can happen.
Anything.
There was one time.
Yes.
Sorry.
All right.
There was one time.
There was a game.
I think it was against.
It was against Egypt guys.
It was like one, like one, two, zero or something.
And the last 10 minutes, Argentina scored like three to four
goals.
Yup.
So like anything can happen.
i need to ask any brits in the stream have y'all heard of
the chip buddy the chip buddy like the england meal the chip
buddy i'm gonna order bangers if england wins i'll get some
bangers for this yeah i ordered some bangers for this banger
game oh girl a chip buddy is literally look it up chip like
ch-i-p-b-u-t-t-y it's just a sandwich with fries in it but
it's just a regular surprise because i'm like you know this
is industrialization free you know the english are very
creative it literally is just french fries in on wood bread
that's crazy also i think like pigs in a hole or something
so you know how usually that's a sausage bun though no but
there's something else they did where like instead of
cutting up the sausage they just put full-on sausages like
in one pan yeah I forget the word for it can anybody remind
me I'm sure we have some Brits I'll show you guys I'll show
them the whole totally the whole why did they not cut up the
sausage why did they not cut up the sausage like this is by
the way this is chip what's it called chip buddy this is a
chip buddy it's literally French fries with ketchup on toast
it's like baby food if you think beans on toast is bad
Ooh, ow, he fell.
Um, I always think about it, like, you know how most men,
not just men, but women too, it's like, you know, if you get
with a man, they'll want you to cook, they'll want you to
cook really good, right?
And like, you know, if their mom is a great cook, you
basically have to compete with like their mommy being this
great cook, right?
And like, God forbid I ever get with an Italian or an, or,
oh, oh, yeah, yeah.
god forbid i ever get with an italian or an indian man and
their mom or their nona is in the kitchen for 12 hours
marinating a sauce you know just the tomato sauce is like a
secret pass down recipe from god right like and then god
bless me if i end up with a british man because i'm like
chip buddy just like your grandma right baby like wow i
visited my grandma for some chip buddy yeah you're such a
great everywhere but there's hard the brits are defending
the english are defending their food oh yeah talk to me talk
to me you're like that's a great sandwich by the way right
we're like imagine the amount of work that comes just to
make like one brisket one like you know you do everything
from scratch it takes forever no no no you know one my
favorite comment why the fuck did they colonize the world to
have no food that's not true that the english got butter
chicken
the english got butter chicken you're right it was invented
in england by who that's a plus one that's a plus one we
they got we at least the commonwealth helped oh oh my god
don't keep my god i admit i wasn't looking that was a insane
shot that was a crazy shot.
There's a replay.
There's going to be a replay.
That's a crazy shot there.
I want to say, I know obviously wanting Lint to win.
I don't really care.
PK.
Player kill.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I love that.
They're like, I love that.
I don't know if they're like cheering at him or cheering
him.
Yeah.
I think you're like, yeah, come on.
I'm mad.
Food me more.
Go.
That was the guy that was praying.
That was the pray boy.
Oh, that was.
Yeah.
No, it lagged.
Don't lag.
Let's see what it's at.
There's a good...
Oh, like, Messi set it up for him.
That's a good setup, assist.
Like, that's a crazy shot.
That's actually...
Like, it literally threaded the needle because there was,
like, so many people in front.
Yeah.
Yeah, and he did it.
I feel so bad for a goalkeeper because he's blocked so many
amazing shots.
The one shot you didn't block.
Oh, Bellingham.
Look at him.
He struck...
He actually came into...
Oh, Bellingham was doing work.
Oh, they need a goal.
i didn't even realize the time they need yeah they need a
goal within another 10 minutes or is going to go to the 30
minute match what does it mean 30 minute match um if it's
tied one one before a penalty kick they yeah at nine in nine
so they're most likely going to add like actually there
haven't been any big fouls so they might it might be like
three to five minutes um but after that if it's still tied
they have to play 15 minutes uh halves so like each half
will be 15 minutes And if nobody scores within that, then it
goes into a shootout.
It goes into a penalty kick.
It really was an excellent shot, genuinely.
Like it actually really was an excellent shot.
They really cooked that one.
You know how like, do you hear about the SC curse where like
there was a VTuber that every team she cheers for, they
lose.
So I asked her if she could start cheering for the Boston
Bruins or the Maple Leafs.
Yeah, I think the real curse is the Miku curse.
You know how the Miku's are being passed down.
But every team only has custody for Miku for one, like for
one game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And every team that has custody for Miku loses so it passes
down.
That has a more of a hundred percent, because that one has a
hundred percent success rate right now.
Until today, because England's going to beat Argentina.
You say this, but it's one-one.
Who's Essie cheering for in this game, you guys?
Everyone's like, it's over.
I believe the reason why it didn't take into effect for the
first France game is that she was reloading.
It had a cool down.
Sometimes even the best me to cool down.
I don't, what the fuck are you doing?
They just stop being aggressive.
Like they're just letting the goal be like on their turf.
Like I have not seen them like be aggressive at all.
I'm not going to lie.
I can't believe it's been almost 90 minutes of.
gameplay it passed by so quick i know yeah no these games
are crazy this is a query the game
oh they're fighting right yellow card yellow card for
apparently if you argue with a ref too hard he will pull a
yellow card a and he pulled him he's like listen buddy i'm
chilling i'm chilling i'm chill guys i'm chill i just want
to talk to you ref he's just oh he's just a It's just like,
I'll never tour in Argentina again.
It's like, I'll never tour there.
Oh, poor baby.
Poor Jagger.
Mick Jagger is sad.
I will say it was kind of a power move after they scored
where he's like, oh, jeer louder.
Yeah.
Like, yeah, come on.
i will say him on the replay mark mark that's invincible he
literally did the invincible meme yeah that's a really cool
yeah i love that that's really that's aura keep talking keep
talking that's talking aura oh shit he's sad think mark i
think i keep seeing young like christiano ronaldo and this
guy he like they have a little bit of that similarity with
like their face no and does anybody else see it or am i just
crazy i don't see it i don't i think you're christ i think
you you're just crazy it's because you don't remember
christiano in like that's true he got he also got eliminated
early too he got eliminated in round of 16.
he's a rage baiter let a man have hobby he's young he's
young anyone would rage bait i rage bait fuels people it's
how he gets stronger wouldn't be on this field rage baiting
people some people just grow stronger
think harry think nah nine minutes of bonus time oh to be
fair wait that's crazy nine minutes and it's like bro
england's got a i england's gotta pick it up bro yeah when i
say it's coming home i meant not you england please you guys
want to watch the football what's wrong why is it england
please because like for england their best bet is to have
another 30 minute set um versus like playing having them
score not all about england because like because like
argentina has the best the best momentum now for this game
so i feel like they they need another they get now they've
also been like really aggressive they've been yeah so they
need a 30 they need a 30 minute game to full reset because
like they're so aggressive right now and the coach can't
like i the coach can't talk to them to like how to play this
right now oh oh my god that was crazy oh my god that was a
crazy shot oh what were you saying about it coming home I'm
just, I'm legitimately just asking, what were you saying
about it coming home?
Do you want to?
Huh?
I'm just saying, I'm just, Doki.
Hey, they could still come.
They got nine minutes, Doki.
They could do it.
I'll be right back, Moti.
You go talk to the chat real quick.
Help me right there.
Please don't kill yourself.
You're way too young and beautiful.
Please, Doki birds, stay with me.
Please.
Don't do it, Doki.
It's not worth it.
dokey it's not worth it life is but yeah how you guys doing
today i think she's going to change clothes i think she's
what are they called in war the turncoats you know before
where people were like i'm just kidding i'm actually on this
side of the war lol that's dokeybird tonight me i believed
in messy and argentina from the start even though all of you
said not to i said i don't care.
I believe in what I want to believe.
I don't care if I'm wrong.
I don't care if I'm the only Argentina defender here.
I will do it.
I'm in, I'm in Los Angeles.
I have to.
Legally speaking.
Doki's always been rooting for Argentina.
We've always been at war with East Asia.
Yeah, yeah.
We've always been at war with Eurasia.
What was it?
East Asia, Oceania.
I forget the other one.
Two plus two is five.
Listen, as I said, it's, it's kind of a joke.
I'm not that about like fandoms and stuff like that but my
joke is as a Eurovision watcher I oh Miku is now Argentinian
Calandria thank you for the soup docie bird is currently
switching oh my god he's a knight huh that was so cute that
was actually really cute that he was a little knight cute
cutie patootie docie bird will be right back in these short
messages in these short minutes um but yeah
listen my joke is always as as a european you never cheer
for britain anywhere so i'm i'm not gonna start now sorry oh
i'm not going to start now bloody balance donkey come back
they're gonna play england has nine minutes to score the
goal dokey come back they're going to show david beckham
victoria beckham's going to show him i've always believed
i've yeah you've always you've always been at war with east
asia yeah yeah two plus two i've always believed what's been
your favorite thing about cheering for argentina today my
boy messy yeah number number number 10 oh boy messy messy so
what are we what are we ordering tonight dokey what are we
what are we what are we i don't i don't i'm trying let's see
if i have i mean genuinely they could still score they have
time oh man they look so defeated 100 prediction rate guys i
mean hey i really need to i really need to talk to sc about
no it's the meeku no it's the meeku curse i the meeku curse
Everyone has Miku custody for one game.
It's a curse.
It's like a curse stall.
It's a fucking curse stall.
Which means...
I mean, also, it's not fully lost yet.
Like, miracles have happened before.
And I know I sound like I'm being sarcastic, but I genuinely
mean it.
Like, they could still score.
They just got to get their head in the game.
Three minutes.
Let me grab a new face.
A new messy face.
i mean do the other guy what was the name of the guy who was
like taunting everybody i don't even know his name you guys
do you know his name wait i'll have to give me a sec let me
redo i gotta disappear for a sec i have like several minutes
until all right there we go grab a new face oh this face is
better let me you want to know how i got these scores you
want to know i got this
Now you're more immersed.
Are you guys more immersed now?
It's that because of Messi's right here It's like he's right
here
He's a little kitty with booty Oh, his butt his butt hurts.
Oh my god.
He's stalling.
He's actually stalling right now His booty his little booty
is like how bright you're watching Messi right now.
It's me Messi I'm both on the field and talking to you to
buy more doctorates.
Remember to buy Doki's doctor.
Guys, I can't believe Doki got messy as a guest.
Yeah, I'm clapping with messy.
Look at that guy's neck muscles.
Did you see that?
Yeah, I did.
Wow, God is good.
I'm one minute and 30 seconds left.
If there's a shirtless man jogging, we look at each other.
We say God is good.
especially with the guy jogging was messy oh he's he's a
well maybe he's a family man but i can still say god is good
if he's this is not my favorite my man is just sad he was
ruining for england he's sad right now listen the newest
dokey in the dokey first is mess messy bird messy dokey
messy bird and they got a minute one of the dokey the dokey
first is literally just messy what if they scored this exact
minute wouldn't it go crazy it would be fucking insane they
literally have 40 seconds left to make this possible come on
it would be piercing them oh it's over argentina can stall
this now it's over they have 30 seconds unless they unless
they grab it oh it's a foul unless they play or kill yeah
but it's to their advantage oh i guess the clock is player
kill too the clock is oh they're so mad oh there's gonna be
a riot oh there's gonna be a riot they're stalling well i'm
trying to wonder if i'm not i'm gonna i don't even know
there's argentina food here look it up look it up you can
probably get something similar like there's a lot of um what
kind of food is in argentina very i'll tell you this very
similar food than in most of latin america the miku curse
continues so you're you're i think like worst case you can
still get um and empanadas yeah look i think if there's an
argentina yeah i want to get an argent a place where there's
like specifically an argentian restaurant they're going to
be in flooded with orders right now yeah i would not be
surprised but also if you campfire in Argentina, I'd go to
like the exactly probably neighboring countries before you
go or then just, you know, let's go.
Oh, no.
England, I, when I said it's coming home, I didn't mean,
England disappoints again.
Who's surprised?
I mean, look, it's a good thing you weren't rooting for
England from the beginning, right?
I knew they were gonna, I knew they were gonna disappoint me
as they've always done.
You just knew from the beginning that you're like, who
you're rooting for.
You knew in your heart of heart that you believe in.
as always i really need them to show david beckham now he's
just gonna be added more time i it's because of the foul
early but it's gonna get called any second now any second
now it's gonna get i just want to see david beckham in tears
crying in his wife's bosom they're coming home they're
coming home come on come on but no one in england is
surprised they always find one way to disappoint us every
time i just have to say i'm surprised you guys weren't
hearing franklin they always find a way no matter what just
to crush our hopes and dreams there's always one one time
every time you're lucky we don't need a visa to go to
england because i don't think they'd like we never win at
home and we never win away the most loyal englishman would
have expected this the most england moment ever
my prediction is that i would die before seeing english
world cup victory is proven right once again oh that's so
awful it's just the english way never have hope for anything
why do you think they're always so depressed like congrats
they're going to the finals wow look at him the little
little school he really did agree they were so aggressive i
feel like the ball was always on the
know what happened like at first and england was like the
way actually like they were putting up like you know an
equal fight with argentina like during the first half and
then the second up they just i don't know they just full out
went on defense but it was just such a it was so risky i
think it's just the scruff the streets of vermouth look at
that 100 prediction ray i've always known i've always you've
always been i've always known how else would i have uh um
messy uh verse messy bird ready locked and loaded i've i've
always known bellingham doesn't even have his boyfriend to
hug right now oh yeah he's all the way in norway right now
he's all
don't look sad i told you it's the me he's like i showed my
leg for nothing yeah that's literally what i was thinking of
like don't look sad just i showed my leg for for nothing.
I told you the Miku curse.
The Miku curse.
I'm fucking, I'm dragging that tweet back.
I fucking knew.
Nobody believed in the curse but me.
That curse has a hundred percent success rate right now.
Where is it?
Where did I tweet it?
There's random people fighting in the background.
That's so funny.
Yeah.
Miku is ours now.
We'll break the curse and become back-to-back champions with
Miku with the helm protect your mate dokey this we're about
three bucks we can't be inflation yet though glad you have
to keep with the akasufa thank you thank you it's okay
football first before you worry about the economy as you
should as you should oh my god the miku curse takes another
that was a really really fun game that was i didn't think it
would be so i wanted to see a red card so quickly that's
crazy they got what three yellow cards total right i love
this i love this tweet wait but darling look at this tweet
uh tell me it never doubted in donald argentina's spirit
alexandra thank you for the aca soup but thank you thank you
that is so funny argentina has decided that instead of
kicking the ball, it would be more productive to kick
English players.
To be fair, English players also, it was like it was also
the same for both sides.
They're like, instead of kicking the ball, let's just kick
Messi.
Like that one time when the first yellow card, yeah, they're
the first yellow card when five people just jumped on Messi.
Yeah.
I think that's every every like strap.
I definitely feel like they were both teams were definitely
like on the aggressive side.
like yeah you can't say like oh it was just one team that
was aggressive no no no they both were punching screaming i
think semi-finals is great no oh my god by the way the world
cup that i watched the france game because it's france
versus england it's on saturday it's the reason why my
outfit reveal was at seven because i had because the game
starts at five so i had a feeling i was like can you read
that one can you read that that uh doki thank you oh thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank you my guitar con
from indepad we love you as a roach and a woman thank you
thank you thank you oh they're calling they're shouting
messi's name they're like messy messy messy messy i they're
shouting my name technically messy messy messy um in the
word of the west is france i might have to cheer for france
that's sorry I'm cheering for England.
I'm the West Coast.
You're, you're the East Coast.
Mbappe.
More like Lbappe.
Lbappe.
Got him.
I've always believed in the power of messy.
Thank you for having me over.
I actually have to get a little bit of work done before in
the stream.
I still, my poor editors are waiting for stuff for me that I
told them I was going to do this morning.
and then we got into this game and i haven't so i gotta i
gotta it's okay it's just like you know one hour it's just a
little an hour break before you go back to work you know
yeah no i really do have to give them some stuff but thank
you for watching with me your first game what a wild game to
watch first my first game in 20 years that's the craziest
part yeah you you got you you actually watched a really
exciting game too yeah i'm not gonna lie it's making me want
to watch game really badly no the okay okay to be fair it's
england versus france because i i was thinking like the only
reason i'll ever watch the bronze game because i i think
like bronze this game is like the constellation prize so
it's obviously like you know it's not as hyped as the finals
um and you're fighting for bronze so yeah but it's england
versus france it's the hunt it's the sequel to the hundred
year war so like i have to watch it i can't believe you're
rooting i want to see you're rooting from the wrong side but
no you're not i'm rooting for english canada I'm rooting for
it.
Yeah, I'm from the English side of Canada You're from the
French side Wow All right, Doki, I wish you all the best of
luck on Saturday I thank you I hope you have a good day
remember everybody buy your Doki bird dog shirts On Saturday
On Saturday
Have a good one okay Thanks for stopping by This was so much
fun.
I still still.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Watch them.
When they would zoom in on their legs and they're so
muscled.
Yeah.
That's like the takeaway you got out of it when they zoom in
on that.
They really need like tighter shirts though.
So that way like that way to eliminate all the problems of
them pulling on their shirts.
They just need tighter shirts.
I'm just saying wouldn't it solve all genuinely.
I'm not even trolling.
Don't you think it would solve the problem?
I think it's like a different type of game you're watching.
watching at that point.
You're watching.
I think at that point, they should invent a new game for
you, just for you.
And then when they get a yellow card, they take off their
shirt and they're like, I guess I'm a journalist.
But because that way, you know which players have the yellow
card.
That's true.
Like I said, it's like strip soccer, strip football.
Also, you know what they should do?
They should always play.
Exactly.
Every 30 minutes, they should do skins versus shirts.
Wow.
I would watch that.
All right.
I'm leaving for real.
I got to get work.
Good luck at work.
Thanks for dropping by.
It was fun.
Yeah.
So fun.
Thanks for watching me.
Bye.
Say bye to Matara.
I'll still talk a little bit.
Give her some, give her some, give her some gifted buy the
merch, buy the merch.
On Saturday.
Bye.
That's really fun.
guys uh batari was like just like last night she was like
can i watch the game with you and i was like yeah you can
drop by of course it's more fun with more people it's like
uh it's like you know like a watch like an actual like you
know sitting in a couch with your friends watching um but
that's crazy i've always believed in messy as you guys can
see i've i've always believed in in our lord and savior
messy 100 prediction rate but argentina now has the cursed
miku i don't know i feel like every time a country holds on
to a miku it only stays in their hands for one for one game
so i don't know why am i talking about my up in the third
person.
Why did it even try?
England will always find a way to disappoint us.
Gave us hope.
Even try to give us hope in the first half.
In the first second half.
Just, what's the point?
True.
They always come home.
They We always came down.
We always think it's different.
We always, always come home.
It's coming home.
England's coming home.
Oh.
They got me.
They always, yeah.
They're going home, all right.
All right, guys, what is, what type of, I don't have it, I
actually don't have, wait, actually, let me Google,
Argentina, they might make my food extra good because of
today.
Maybe, guys, maybe they'll make my food really, really good
just because of today.
All right, there is a restaurant, but I don't know if they
have,
I don't know if they have a, like oh wait they do wait how
far is this i'm trying not i i caught myself to not say it
out loud of the restaurant do i have this do they do it
takeout
oh i don't think they do i got that this is a restaurant
with reservations all right i'm checking guys i need an
argentina restaurant Francis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I said, I don't know any types of Argentinean food.
So I need you to educate me because I actually don't know.
I'm like trying to find it.
I'm trying to find it.
Oh my God.
This is the only restaurant.
There's only one restaurant.
There's actually only...
Oh, it's because it has a Michelin star.
That's why.
Okay, that makes sense.
That's that makes sense.
It's a Michelin star restaurant.
It's the only Argentinian restaurant near like not I only
say near me, but like I guess like in my city and like it's
a Michelin star restaurant.
So I don't think they do take out guys.
Asada.
What's it called?
Asada?
Oh, there's Asada here.
Is that like the closest thing?
I can get all right I have what is this called I have polo
assado is that close enough oh god it's so far it's polo
assado close enough and assadito okay assadito I'll heart
this just in case
oh it's not okay assadito guys I don't think it's crazy.
I don't think they like they live here
For some reason I don't think I don't think any Argentinians
live here.
I can't find any Any Argentinian food.
There's only one.
There's literally only one There's only one restaurant and
they don't do takeout
No way.
Like, there might be, like, one or two.
But, like, right now, I have not found a single restaurant
that sells, like, Argentine food in Uber Eats.
There's no Asado!
There's actually no Asado.
Wait, I have...
I have Karnasado.
I don't think that's the same thing.
You can't believe England lost.
England always finds a way to disappoint us.
It was just today.
Maybe I ordered empanada.
I'm pretty sure there's empanada.
There's only polo asada.
That's it.
I think we have to go with empanada.
I think that's the only thing.
Oh, yeah.
Oh,
my God.
Guys, I just realized the finals is the colonizer versus the
colonized.
This is the matchup.
Not only are we going to get the 100-year-old sequel.
They're going to fight the colonizer.
They're going to fight Spain.
Impanada.
They have, I'm pretty sure.
empanada earlier all right the war and the colonization oh
latino versus neo-latino it's for the culture they're gonna
get double independence the hundred year war in third for
third place all right there is empanada wait is there okay
the photos do not look as good as I would like right now
from this there's a no that's enchilada where the fuck is
there no impalat I okay I found one it's at a big bakery and
it's a beef impanada like what there's like oh there's a
place that just sells empanadas it's literally only oh but
they're all like frozen is there like okay fresh empanada
it's literally a restaurant just for that i also just find
out that el boppe has lost against yamel like nine times in
a row is it nine times in a row that's crazy that's that's
actually crazy all right do i get beef or chicken empanada i
found a bakery That sells it.
Oh, this bakery is not far.
Don't even order.
Fuck it.
Beef?
That's literally the only thing I could find.
That's literally the only empanada.
Like, there's nothing else.
Luckily, this bakery sells empanadas and it's super close
by.
All right, first meal of the day.
I also want something to drink.
We have a second stream today.
We have a second stream.
All right, let's see.
Let me...
Oh!
Who is this guy that he's interviewing?
Does he have messy tattooed on his arm?
Like, what is that on his arm?
We're doing a second stream today.
Because I want to play a game.
It's a chill game, though.
I'm going to work at a post office.
I mean, I'm a cat.
What's a...
What is this?
all right let's grab this and i need a drink too it's like
super close by i'm still gonna i'm still gonna order an uber
i really don't want to go outside right now
i'm really i'm really out of it
all right let's see is there other other beverages i don't
want other hot beverages i mean like cold the only thing
they have is cold it's like caffeine That sucks.
I'm just ordering food right now.
I would actually, at least like, there's a lot of British
people living here who's surprised.
So it's very easy to get British food.
I've never realized how hard it is to get Argentine food
here.
I did not realize it was that bad.
I didn't realize how bad it is.
Never thought about it.
Never got Argentinian food.
The fact that there's only one restaurant that sells like,
like, Argentinian food is crazy.
Like, here.
We need to fill the gap.
We need to fill the market.
All right, let me make the, I'll make the waiting room for
the next stream right now.
Let's see.
because I we haven't been playing games and we gotta get
like uh we gotta have a game before all the gamer goons
disappear we got it's been 20 years since turkey played a
video game so I gotta I gotta put a game in here like you
stream video games what a crazy game though what a fucking
crazy game when was last time i streamed a video game that's
been a while i don't know it's actually it actually has been
i'm slowly but because also i for didn't realize that my my
stream categories have been on gaming instead of sports
because i forgot that you know i forgot that existed uh so i
had to i had to like i swapped it later on i think like last
stream But that's like, but play something other than, other
than rivals.
Oh my God, look at him.
That's crazy.
He's got the, why is he shirtless?
Yeah, I didn't want to play, like, I didn't want to do a
gaming series today, but I want to do something more
relaxing.
So we're doing, what's the game called?
Cat mail call.
Cat mail.
I wanted to, like, do something to, before I a's back into
it.
Is Kanapu still on strike?
It's still on.
I don't know.
Did we fix that yet or no?
Are we still on strike?
I can't tell.
We've been on strike on and off for like two plus years.
I don't know.
I'll Google that.
Any, all the Canadians left as soon as they can.
got knocked out they don't care anymore about the world cup
ever since we stopped hosting the world cup all the
canadians are gone uh is canada post still still on strike
um is not currently on strike okay nice all right canada
post is not on okay not is not on strike anymore
Gotta go back to work.
It's gotta be sure.
I can't tell.
They're like back and forth all the time.
We've been like back and forth, so I could never tell.
But yeah, the reason why the schedule was super late this
week is because we had to coordinate the...
Oh, God, that was an insane goal from Argentina, though.
Was because...
We had to coordinate the special announcement with Iron
Mouse, Rin, and Amelie.
And it was like a back and forth and everything.
And so like today, thank God I didn't post the schedule
yesterday.
Because I was planning on posting it yesterday.
But then we found out that we had to do on Sunday because
Mousy wasn't feeling so good.
She's sick this week.
So we want to give her more time to recover.
So we had to push it a Sunday.
So that's why.
And also had to think about the...
I was thinking about the bronze match, too.
So because of that, I had to, like, figure out if I had to
swap the outfit reveal with the announcement.
So because, like, the outfit reveal was going to be on
Sunday because I was like, okay, I don't want to have, like,
you know, the announcement and also watching the World Cup
and also outfit reveal.
So originally, the outfit reveal was going to be on Sunday.
And then later on, found out that we had to swap.
I had to rearrange the schedule because we confirmed it on
Saturday, like, I think two days ago.
And then yesterday, we found out that, like, we couldn't do
it.
So then I'd do, like, you know, I didn't want to post
anything yet until we have full confirmation because this is
a very important announcement.
So, yeah, Sunday is the announcement that we'll finally find
out what we were doing, what we've been doing.
On Sunday at 3 p.m.
PST.
I think it's only me and Mousy streaming that.
So one will be on Twitch and I'll be on YouTube.
so and then uh rena and melina would be on our channels so
because then we want to be like so like all the youtube
video viewers can go instead of splitting all of us up uh
splitting all the viewers up so then we have like we're
conjugating on twitch side and on youtube side um so yeah
that's gonna be on sunday uh i mean and i'll riff it reveal
on uh saturday i will post the silhouette and the waiting
room after this stream there's so many tweets to do like to
this week in general also if you guys are wondering um the
um i won't i won't say what it's the doki cut because uh uh
but if you have the streaming tickets for doki doki rewind
time a new version is up on um on spawn that shows more of
the choreo uh of sender shots but it's not i won't i won't
say it's the doki cut because they were so rushed in editing
all of it there were some little things that uh was
overlooked were some edits that um i wasn't like super happy
about in terms of i want to say super happy but like i wrote
like a guide but because like we had to like have it pushed
out and like we had to push out before the before the
tickets are like before the the deadline is gone um so i
couldn't do any corrections or anything that i wanted to do
because they added stuff that I didn't want it to be added
or then they removed stuff that I didn't want to be removed
because there's like a bit there was a little
miscommunication yet the mouse on the side and everything
the white board on the top they're all gone um but I
couldn't we couldn't fix it in time so it's tech it's not
the joki cut it's the cut that shows more of the choreo so
it's it's more of the center shot so you can actually see
more of the choreo unfortunately like you know I'm such a
perfect I'm so hard on myself I'm such a perfectionist and I
you guys to know i paid for the edits on my own with my own
money um because it was something extra that i wanted to do
for you guys so it was like around like it was like around
900 so it came out of my it came out of like my uh my
personal funds for this because i did it for you guys
because it was a little extra thing i did for you guys um
because i want you guys to have a better you had to see more
of the choreo and everything because i always want to
improve some stuff so like i didn't have to do it like
they're like oh you don't have to do it but i was like no i
want to like they're like you have to pay for you want to do
it and i was like i'll pay i was i was like okay i'll pay
for it um so but i won't say it's the dokey cut because like
there are some things that are removed and swapped or added
in that like um that i thought like should be added back in
and stuff but we couldn't have we didn't have time to thank
you yeah i know i have messy i'm i'm saying all this with
the messy guys i'm committed uh thank you messy bird you're
welcome i'm staying on this with messy talking to you
because it was like so i spent like five i spent like five
plus hours like combing writing a little instruction guide
of it but there was like a little miscommunication um
because like um i didn't realize that they weren't following
my instruction guide like um like directly because they got
there was a little miscommunication they like added some
stuff in room some stuff that wasn't in my little guide that
I wrote like so that's why I won't say it's a dokey cut um
it's like it's an edit but I do think like I think like it
can't it's not the vision I have in my head you know like
it's not the perfect cut um it can be a lot better but like
you can you can see the more of the choreo though for this
one so if you like you know for the nimi section every time
we touched it was kind of doing close-ups but i they made it
so that you can actually see the choreo of what we were
doing when i was teaching her how to fortnite dance and
stuff like that so um oh hey there's an interview with mr
harry kane yeah it's the tv edit i would say yeah so so
that's up um what else is there else is there but yeah
that's why the schedule is a little late oh yeah i wanted to
show you as a silhouette all right so i'll post this too so
here's the silhouette guys here's the silhouette for i can't
take this so seriously right now oh he didn't lose his voice
this time yet so so this is the the silhouette of the the ep
update the the ep patch notes so new sleepwear slash pajama
pajama bird epi dokey is ditch evolving too yeah we're gonna
we're gonna evolve epi bird yeah so this is the the
silhouette for it all right so yeah i think that's
everything i'm pretty sure oh yeah i need to finish making
my waiting room guys give me a sec i still forgot about that
uh so i can raid myself uh let me delete all of this was it
called again i already forgot the name of this game cat mel
ko um that's it
Yo, kitty.
All right, I think that's everything.
All right, I'm making my way downtown.
Walking fast and I'm homebound.
Oh, yeah, and for the individual uploads of 99 Red Balloons
and Feel Good, that will be done later because I wanted to
edit it.
I wanted to edit it a bit more because, like I said, it
didn't follow the vision I had because they only had like
one and a half two days.
to edit this and I and because of how rushed it I couldn't
get any input it's just one and done like after they're done
with editing this like we have to just upload it so uh so
but now but for the individual uploads I have more time in
this in um making the vision I had of like how how I wanted
to cut so for that that will be like a little later maybe
like next month or later this month um end of this month or
beginning of next month uh so uh so we're gonna have because
i want to have that improved on in terms of like cameras and
stuff so that's why because i have more time to do that like
it's not like one and done like here's the video upload
so so uh so this time so that one i would have more time to
look into that's why it's gonna be look we have to uh have
the another editor look through it and everything all right
let me upload the waiting room um let's see is that the
correct tab all right nice i do a lot after the stream i
have to go back to work mode because i i might have not
responded to any work messages last night because um i have
no excuse i took a nap and then um it didn't turn into a nap
it might have been a it might have i took a nap and then i
woke up and i was like i have streamed today i i was like oh
i have a stream like in an hour i lost a nap the thing is i
also napped right after the game yesterday too um so i
napped there And then I went and then I woke up did some a
bit of work stuff, but not a lot of work stuff And I was
like, I'm tired again.
I'm gonna nap again.
I'm gonna nap like two to three hours and I woke up and I
was like Oh, that was a whoa, that was a long time.
I was gone for it
That was a long time.
All right, let's see.
All right, guys.
I'm gonna call it here everybody Um, I'll see you on
Saturday as well for the the hundred year war sequel of
England versus France so I guess I'll see you there too
we're gonna have another England we're gonna have England
versus France on Saturday but pre before the outfit reveal
so um so like I said we'll see who gets to win the bronze
medal that's so sad
as always everybody look even Al Lent did was like all in on
Al Lent was all in on england winning that they didn't even
give me any but usually when they they would have something
emergency backup prepared but even al led believed are you
just are you disappointed welcome to the english experience
like that's how they feel all the time like so he had the
one time they didn't prep
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and put around
to get that blood flowing if you stay up for me head to bed
or maybe stay up for my actual guys you know i'm a gaming
streamer i play video games um the world cup is not the only
soccer is not the only thing i do um so you guys want to
know what other content i actually do uh maybe stay up for
tonight's stream hey guys i'll see you guys later everybody
bye guys Bye.